Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Episode 17, Java. Take it away, Patrick. All right, mixing it up this week. So having a young daughter and talking to other people at work
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。第 17 期，Java。Patrick，请开始你的表演。好的，这周我们换个话题。作为一个有年幼女儿的父亲，在工作中和其他有小孩的人交流时
with young kids we were having a discussion the other day which I thought was interesting about playing video games with your kids so obviously my daughter is far too young to play video games unfortunately it would be a nice excuse to play even more video games than normal I saw a one year old playing anger birds the other day
我们前几天讨论了一个我觉得很有趣的话题，就是和孩子一起玩电子游戏。显然，我的女儿还太小，没法玩电子游戏，遗憾的是，这本来可以成为我玩更多游戏的绝佳借口。我前几天看到一个一岁大的孩子在玩《愤怒的小鸟》。
were they doing it well? they were not they weren't doing too bad i mean like in other words like the bird was moving you know they weren't getting a high score or anything but like you know they could see that i think the one year old was starting to figure out that like you know if they moved their finger a different way the bird did something different they're kind of starting to get the whole like the bird doesn't go as far if you move your finger down or whatever oh wow they're doing the i was impressed that's pretty good yeah i it's a hard it's a hard thing so um there's different classes you can try to play like an educational style games like i remember growing up you know you had these games which would teach you math you know you would run around the level
他们玩得好吗？他们玩得不好，但也还行。我的意思是，换句话说，小鸟在移动，你知道的，他们并没有得到高分什么的，但你能看出，我觉得那个一岁大的孩子开始意识到，如果他们用不同的方式移动手指，小鸟就会有不同的反应。他们开始理解整个逻辑，比如如果你把手指往下移，小鸟就飞不远之类的。哦，哇，他们居然在做这个。我印象深刻，这相当不错。是的，这是一件很难的事情。所以，嗯，有一些不同类型的游戏你可以尝试，比如教育类游戏。我记得我小时候，你知道，有一些游戏会教你数学，你会在关卡里跑来跑去，
and try to hit the blocks like the cookie monster one where you had to like add the cookies yeah and there's all these you know but those are kind of overtly educational right like obviously this is you're learning you know and at the expense of gameplay and then there's like trying to do gameplay that is you know truly engaging for a kid and maybe trying to mix learning in it like I guess there's some learning to be had in Angry Birds like you said like trajectories type stuff I mean that's kind of interesting I don't know how much a one-year-old cares about trajectory unless they find a slingshot but maybe you know yeah it's like the
尝试去撞击方块，就像那个《芝麻街》里的甜饼怪游戏，你需要把饼干加起来。是的，还有所有这些，你知道的，但那些都过于强调教育性了，对吧？很明显你是在学习，而且是以牺牲游戏性为代价的。然后还有那种试图在游戏性上真正吸引孩子，并尝试融入学习内容的游戏。我想《愤怒的小鸟》里也有一些学习内容，就像你说的，关于轨迹之类的东西。我的意思是，这很有趣。我不知道一岁大的孩子是否关心轨迹，除非他们找到了弹弓，但也许，你知道，是的，这就像是
bigger thing of like the consequence of like or just knowing that like there's this spectra here like if you go like too far on one end and you go too far in the other end next time you go in the middle or something. I mean like there's some core concepts there. So I guess my debate was how soon, you know, not that it's a big deal, but how soon do I want to start introducing video games? Because if you see like a one-year-old playing Angry Birds, they can maybe play it, they can launch the bird,
更宏大的概念，比如因果关系，或者只是知道这里有一个范围。如果你在一端走得太远，在另一端也走得太远，下次你就会尝试走中间之类的。我的意思是，这里面有一些核心概念。所以我猜我的争论点是，多早，你知道，并不是说这很重要，但我多早想开始引入电子游戏？因为如果你看到一个一岁大的孩子在玩《愤怒的小鸟》，他们也许能玩，他们可以发射小鸟，
but they're not really understanding it. Yeah, that's true. I mean, if they're enjoying it, okay. Are they learning anything? Is there something you could be doing that would help them learn more? Right. Does it matter? Like, you know, these kind of questions.
但他们并不真正理解它。是的，那是真的。我的意思是，如果他们玩得开心，那也行。他们学到了什么吗？有什么事情是你本可以做来帮助他们学到更多的吗？对。这重要吗？就像，你知道，这类问题。
Because when I was hanging out with my cousins a while ago, one of them had a Nintendo DS and a Super Mario on the Nintendo DS. And, of course, you know, when I was, you know, young, first, second, third, fourth grade, I don't remember when we started having video games. But we had to play, you know, Mario or whatever. I would get to the first level, second level, and then second, third, fourth grade. I don't remember when we started having video games. But we had to play Mario or whatever. I would get to the first level, second level, and then die, and there was no save games. And I would just play over and over again, and it was really difficult.
因为前段时间我和表亲们在一起时，其中一个有任天堂 DS 和《超级马里奥》。当然，你知道，当我年轻的时候，小学一、二、三、四年级，我不记得我们什么时候开始有电子游戏的。但我们必须玩，你知道，马里奥什么的。我会玩到第一关、第二关，然后……小学一、二、三、四年级。我不记得我们什么时候开始有电子游戏的。但我们必须玩马里奥什么的。我会玩到第一关、第二关，然后死掉，而且没有存档。我就只能一遍又一遍地玩，这真的很难。
Now I can play and like, yay, I can get to level five before dying. So, of course, my cousin thinks like, oh, Uncle Patrick's amazing at playing Mario. I'll have him beat this level for me. But then it's like they actually it doesn't help them because they observe me play but it's all like this subtle timing so then every time they get stuck instead of like toughing it out themselves and learning they just want to ask me like oh hey can you now be it's like no you know either I'm too busy and I don't want to or like you know this isn't helping you me just keep beating these levels for you like
现在我可以玩了，就像，耶，我可以在死掉之前玩到第五关。所以，当然，我的表亲觉得，哦，帕特里克叔叔玩马里奥太厉害了。我要让他帮我通关这一关。但后来发现，这实际上对他们没有帮助，因为他们观察我玩，但这全靠微妙的时机把握。所以每次他们卡住时，与其自己坚持下去并学习，他们只想问我，哦，嘿，你能帮我通关吗？就像，不，你知道，要么我很忙，我不想，要么，你知道，我一直帮你通关这对你没有帮助，就像
you know you're not getting anything out of it but, there was a long time before I was able to ever, like, get a game to where I could beat it that wasn't a kid's game. Yeah. One thing that's kind of weird is I went back and played some old games on the Wii Virtual Console. Okay. So, you know, went back and bought Mario and Zelda and stuff. And I was actually much better at these games.
你知道，你从中什么也没得到。但是，在我能够玩通一个不是儿童游戏的关卡之前，经历了很长一段时间。是的。有一件很奇怪的事情是，我回去在 Wii 虚拟主机上玩了一些老游戏。好的。所以，你知道，回去买了马里奥和塞尔达之类的。我实际上比以前玩得好多了。
Yes. I was, like, nine. You remember them being, like, incredibly difficult. And now they're hard. But even more so, like, i remember being way better at them oh you were better before yeah oh like i went to play and i think what it is i think i had more patience because the cost is high right like if you know you're playing megaman like you're playing to beat the game you know what i mean like when you're nine now when i Mega Man, I know that something's going to distract me in, like, half an hour.
是的。我当时大概九岁。你记得它们当时看起来非常难。现在它们依然很难。但更重要的是，我记得我以前玩得好多了。哦，你以前玩得更好？是的，我去玩的时候，我想原因是我当时更有耐心，因为代价很高，对吧？如果你知道你在玩《洛克人》，你是为了通关而玩，你明白我的意思吗？就像你九岁的时候。现在当我玩《洛克人》时，我知道半小时内肯定会有事情打断我。
Like, I know I just don't have the block of time to beat the game. So I play, like, more reckless, and maybe that's part of it. But, yeah, basically I can't get, like, even half as far as I could when I was a little kid. Wow. I think it's also, like, a lot of those games you needed to essentially memorize the level and the timing. That's true, too. I also don't have patience for that. Yeah, so I'm comparing myself having not played for 20 years,
就像，我知道我没有整块的时间来通关。所以我玩得更鲁莽，也许这就是原因的一部分。但是，是的，基本上我连小时候能玩到的一半进度都达不到。哇。我觉得这也是因为很多那些游戏你基本上需要记住关卡和时机。那也是真的。我也没有耐心做那个。是的，所以我是在拿没玩过 20 年的自己，
playing for the first time, versus myself at the end of having played for six months straight. Right, yeah. Also, there is a thing out there on the internet. People talk about games are becoming easier, right? So you have saves, then continuous save, or walk away, or you can just checkpoint way too often or have too many lives.
第一次玩，和我连续玩了六个月后的自己做比较。对，是的。另外，互联网上有一种说法。人们说游戏变得越来越简单了，对吧？所以你有存档，然后是连续存档，或者随时离开，或者你可以太频繁地设置检查点，或者有太多的生命值。
Now the common thing in first person shooters is not to have to go collect health but you get shot and you just go hide behind a box for a few seconds and then your health is charged back up or whatever. So I mean these things are making games easier. I always feel like that was sort of like a cop out because I think
现在第一人称射击游戏里的常见做法是不需要去收集生命值，你被击中了，只要躲在箱子后面几秒钟，你的生命值就会恢复，或者类似的情况。所以我的意思是这些事情让游戏变得更容易了。我一直觉得那有点像是一种逃避，因为我认为
what that does is when you have these things like a lot of checkpoints and saves, what it does is it makes you spend more time focusing on like the real problem, right? And less time like replaying. So, for example, like Mario, we all have to play World 1-1 a million times, right? But if we had, you know, a checkpoint every level level then we would spend more time on the harder levels like getting the important skills you know yeah so there's really like a exclamation uh you know a point to be made either way i guess at the end though you don't have the satisfaction of i went through the whole game in one sitting right yeah no it's an interesting thing so
当你有这些东西，比如大量的检查点和存档时，它所做的是让你花更多时间专注于真正的问题，对吧？而不是花时间重玩。所以，例如，像马里奥，我们都必须把 1-1 关玩上一百万次，对吧？但如果我们每一关都有一个检查点，那么我们就会花更多时间在更难的关卡上，学习重要的技能。你知道，是的，所以无论如何都有一个值得指出的点。我想最后，你没有那种我一次性通关整个游戏的满足感，对吧？是的，不，这是一件有趣的事情，所以
i didn't really uh have a amazing point there but just i was thinking about this kids and games and whether my childhood playing games was good too much too little games yeah you know what should it be now and i wonder like are we going to be those parents that like tell our kids to go play outside like our parents did you know because i feel like you have to at some level like you need to understand there's a world outside of games and computers and video. I think that's an important aspect. But on the other hand, there's some parents
我并没有什么惊人的观点，只是我在思考这些孩子和游戏，以及我童年玩游戏是好是坏，是太多还是太少。是的，你知道现在应该是什么样？我想知道，我们是否会成为那种告诉孩子去外面玩，就像我们父母那样做的父母？你知道，因为我觉得在某种程度上你必须这样做，你需要明白游戏和电脑、视频之外还有一个世界。我认为这是一个重要的方面。但另一方面，有些父母
who don't let their kids have any computer time and game time. And I don't know. I feel like in order... It's such a part of society now, and getting a job, especially if your child may show a predisposition to wanting to get into something technical or computer-related. Like understanding those skills are important and good to learn early and have time to practice.
不让他们的孩子有任何电脑时间和游戏时间。我不知道。我觉得为了……这现在是社会的一部分，而且对于找工作来说，特别是如果你的孩子可能表现出想要进入技术或计算机相关领域的倾向。理解这些技能很重要，而且尽早学习并有时间练习是件好事。
If your child wants to listen to programming throwdown, you should let them. That's a general rule that we've found. Yes, yes, yes. So talking about games, a new Kickstarter that was all the rage, I guess it's now a little bit of an old story, but it's okay. The OUYA? Yeah. OUYA! OUYA! kickstarter that was all the rage i guess it's now a little bit of an old story but this is okay the ooyah yeah yeah this thing's pretty awesome um basically what they did is they took the android os and um they created sort of an interface for the tv so it runs android it connects up to your tv i guess hd HDMI or something like that. And then it has these Bluetooth controllers that they look kind of like the Xbox controller,
如果你的孩子想听《编程抛头论足》(Programming Throwdown)，你应该让他们听。这是我们发现的一条通用规则。是的，是的，是的。说到游戏，一个新的 Kickstarter 项目非常火爆，我想现在它已经是一个有点旧的故事了，但没关系。OUYA？是的。OUYA！OUYA！Kickstarter 项目非常火爆，我想现在它已经是一个有点旧的故事了，但这没关系。OUYA，是的，是的，这个东西非常棒。嗯，基本上他们所做的是他们采用了安卓操作系统，嗯，他们为电视创建了一个界面，所以它运行安卓系统，它连接到你的电视，我猜是 HDMI 或类似的东西。然后它有这些蓝牙控制器，它们看起来有点像 Xbox 控制器，
like they're kind of designed to fit well. And it looks like it's going to have dual analog sticks and all that. And, yeah, the idea is you can play all these Android games in a TV setting. And their whole mantra is bring gaming back to the living room because the idea is, you know, I mean, we haven't seen a new Xbox in a while. We haven't seen a new PlayStation. I think a lot of these console companies, they don't really know what to do. They feel like
就像它们的设计是为了握感舒适。看起来它会有双模拟摇杆等等。而且，是的，想法是你可以在电视环境下玩所有这些安卓游戏。他们的整个口号是把游戏带回客厅，因为想法是，你知道，我的意思是，我们已经很久没有看到新的 Xbox 了。我们还没有看到新的 PlayStation。我认为很多这些游戏机公司，他们真的不知道该做什么。他们觉得
things are sort of leaving the living room and so much more money is to be made online making these casual games for your phone and things like that. So this is sort of an attempt to create an open platform, something that's never really existed in the console world, and bring gaming back to the living room. And it seems pretty cool.
事情正在离开客厅，而且在线制作这些手机休闲游戏之类的东西能赚更多的钱。所以这算是一种尝试，创建一个开放平台，这是游戏机世界中从未真正存在过的东西，并把游戏带回客厅。这看起来很酷。
Yeah, I like the idea of what they're trying to do. I wonder if they haven't bit off more than they can chew. I mean, they seem like they have some sort of experience in the field, so that's good. But I do agree that we kind of tried to get there right like this casual gaming thing for your tv and in that way i felt that it was successful for me the week comes out when i have a lot of people over to the house or something i don't ever play it when i'm just like me like i want to play something because the graphics aren't very good it's kind of silly to be sitting there
是的，我喜欢他们试图做的事情。我想知道他们是否有点贪多嚼不烂。我的意思是，他们看起来在这一领域有一些经验，所以这很好。但我确实同意我们有点试图达到那个目标，对吧？比如电视上的休闲游戏，从这个角度来看，我觉得它对我来说是成功的。Wii 出来的时候，当家里有很多人或者类似的情况时，我从来不会在只有我一个人的时候玩它，因为图形不是很好，坐在那里动来动去有点傻。
moving around i don't know if that's me but i feel like the this uio console could be like it's like iphone games but on the tv and for your family or for when friends come over and it really could be that fun and exciting thing especially if they you know kind of embrace that as opposed to saying we're going to be a gamers game thing then i don't i mean maybe it'll be good it could be there's a lot of good games out there for even the mobile platforms yeah i mean i think a couple of cool things or a couple of things to know one is i think it'd be super cool if they somehow integrated the ouya with your phones so like for example like a simple example might be uh you know it's some kind of multiplayer like rpg game let's say and you carry your character on your phone. And then when you go to your friend's house.
我不知道那是不是我，但我感觉这个 OUYA 游戏机可能就像是电视上的 iPhone 游戏，为了你的家庭或者朋友来访时准备的，它真的可能成为那种有趣且令人兴奋的东西，特别是如果他们，你知道，拥抱这一点，而不是说我们要成为一个硬核玩家的游戏机。所以我不知道，我的意思是，也许它会很好。这很有可能，即使是移动平台也有很多好游戏。是的，我的意思是，我认为有几件很酷的事情，或者几件需要知道的事情，一是如果他们能以某种方式将 OUYA 与你的手机集成，那会非常酷。所以，例如，一个简单的例子可能是，嗯，你知道，某种多人 RPG 游戏，假设你把你的角色带在手机上。然后当你去朋友家时。
Yeah, you're both playing together. Oh, interesting. I didn't think about that. The classic one is, and I think this is the one, though, new Wii, Wii U, is it, I guess? It's supposed to have tablets, and it's like you're playing football, and instead of having the plays up on the screen, you have to hide what button you're pushing.
是的，你们都在一起玩。哦，有趣。我没想过那个。经典的一个是，而且我认为这是那个，虽然，新的 Wii，Wii U，是吗，我猜？它应该有平板电脑，就像你在玩橄榄球，而不是把战术显示在屏幕上，你必须隐藏你按下的按钮。
Like you have it on your screen, and so you can make the play or draw an audible or whatever and the other person has no idea or you're playing like a board game right this is kind of cool you're playing a board game and the board is on the tv but your pieces and your character are on your phone yeah that would be your making selection yeah yeah so i think there's a ton of cool stuff they can make it to where even a single player game let's say it was some game that had, like, it was, like, an FPS, but there's, like, a strategy element to it. So, like, maybe when you're at work, like, in your off time or whatever,
就像你在屏幕上有它，所以你可以制定战术或画出战术，或者其他什么，而另一个人完全不知道，或者你在玩像棋盘游戏一样的东西。这很酷，你在玩棋盘游戏，棋盘在电视上，但你的棋子和角色在你的手机上。是的，那将是你的选择。是的，是的，所以我认为他们可以做很多很酷的事情，甚至是一个单人游戏，假设它是一个 FPS 游戏，但里面有一个策略元素。所以，也许当你在工作时，在你的空闲时间或其他什么时间，
you'd be on your phone, like, doing the strategy part so that when you come home you can, like, fight the battle that you've been, like, preparing for. You know, something like that. Like, there's just so much potential. That's true. Or, like, the immersive-style games, they try to do this for a while where, like, you're at work and you – maybe gets too much like farmville i guess but uh you know something
你会在手机上做策略部分，这样当你回家时，你可以进行你一直在准备的战斗。你知道，类似的东西。就像，有太多的潜力了。那是真的。或者，像沉浸式游戏，他们尝试做这个有一段时间了，就像，你在工作，你——也许这变得太像《开心农场》了，我想，但嗯，你知道，某种
you have like a notification comes up that like hey you know your person is fighting on the lines at home you know you need to like go in and drop into this mini game and help them out or go into a little battle you know whatever and then when you get home you can like wage the war or whatever but yeah or maybe like your whole family is fighting the battle at the same time so like you might be playing the game and like uh your wife might be like on her phone at work and she gets a notification like i don't know plays minigame to help out maybe this is just starting to sound like too much like work than a game i don't know so so that idea to me is very appealing and having low cost open hardware is good.
你收到一个通知，比如嘿，你知道你的角色在家里前线战斗，你知道你需要进入这个小游戏并帮助他们，或者进入一场小战斗，你知道，无论什么，然后当你回家时，你可以发动战争或者其他什么。但是的，或者也许你的整个家庭同时在进行战斗，所以你可能在玩游戏，而你的妻子可能在工作时用手机，她收到一个通知，比如我不知道，玩个小游戏来帮忙。也许这听起来太像工作而不是游戏了，我不知道。所以那个想法对我来说非常有吸引力，而且拥有低成本的开放硬件是件好事。
The thing that I skipped about, I guess, with the Ouya is they're trying to have their game store, right? And you go to them, but they're taking, as opposed to like an upfront fee to go with an Xbox and then a recurring licensing fee or whatever, they're just trying to make it kind of the same app store model and then requiring everything to have at least some free-to-play element, which is great.
关于 OUYA 我跳过的一件事是，我想他们试图拥有自己的游戏商店，对吧？你去他们那里，但他们正在采取，而不是像 Xbox 那样预付费用，然后是经常性的许可费或其他什么，他们只是试图让它成为某种应用商店模式，然后要求所有东西至少有一些免费游戏元素，这很棒。
But I don't really want another closed place for games. I want a console that's like my PC. I can just download whatever I want, play whatever I want. If someone wants to make an open-source version, great. I did that. And maybe you will support those kinds of people can bring free stuff and it not be a hassle or a problem for them.
但我真的不想要另一个封闭的游戏场所。我想要一个像我的 PC 一样的游戏机。我可以下载任何我想要的，玩任何我想要的。如果有人想制作一个开源版本，太好了。我做到了。也许你会支持那些人，他们可以带来免费的东西，而且这对他们来说不是麻烦或问题。
And I really hope that's true. I think that they said that all the games have to be free. Like, the only money that can be spent is on in-app purchases. Well, I think it's like, it sounded like a demo, right? Like, you get the first level, and then an in-app purchase for all the rest of the levels. Yeah, right. So, okay, I mean, but what about somebody who doesn't want to pay anything? And I didn't read it that closely.
我真的希望这是真的。我想他们说所有的游戏都必须是免费的。就像，唯一能花的钱是在应用内购买上。嗯，我想这就像是一个演示，对吧？就像，你得到第一关，然后应用内购买剩下的所有关卡。是的，对。所以，好吧，我的意思是，但是对于那些不想付任何钱的人呢？我没有读得那么仔细。
Oh, I see. But, like, what if you just wanted to release, like, hey, here's this crazy thing called uh trivopedia and i want to release it for you and you just want to sell it for you know i don't want to name to it or something yeah like will will that be okay and they've said oh without being rootable then the issue is always once you root it there's problems with subverting the purchasing mechanisms right in the store so then they try to probably not let you be in the store if you have it rooted. I don't know. We'll see. It'll be interesting.
哦，我明白了。但是，如果你只是想发布，比如，嘿，这里有一个疯狂的东西叫 Trivopedia，我想为你发布它，你只是想卖掉它，你知道，我不想给它命名或者其他什么。是的，这可以吗？他们说哦，如果不进行 Root，那么问题总是，一旦你 Root 了它，就会出现破坏商店购买机制的问题，对吧？所以他们可能试图不让你在 Root 的情况下进入商店。我不知道。我们会看到的。这会很有趣。
So I haven't backed it. Have you? No, not yet. One more thing before I talk about it is one thing they haven't addressed is the fact that all of these games so far, like all the ones they list, they were all designed for a touchscreen. They weren't really designed for a touchscreen. So the controllers have a touchscreen on them, like a touch-sensitive mousepad thing. Oh, really?
所以我还没有支持它。你支持了吗？不，还没有。在我谈论它之前还有一件事，他们还没有解决的一个事实是，到目前为止所有的这些游戏，就像他们列出的所有游戏，它们都是为触摸屏设计的。它们并不是真的为触摸屏设计的。所以控制器上有一个触摸屏，就像一个触摸敏感的鼠标垫之类的东西。哦，真的吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. See, how come they don't have any... that if you look there in the middle between the joysticks or whatever between the analog sticks there's like a little pad and you're supposed to but there's a lot of people are questioning like how are they going to do this so it's essentially a phone type motherboard in the box you know and then but then these controllers are supposedly going to be nice perfect so are they even going to be able to make like is the price too low? $100 I mean this is way lower than any other, you know, I mean Microsoft, Xbox I guess
是的，是的，是的。看，为什么他们没有……如果你看摇杆之间，或者模拟摇杆之间，有一个小垫子，你应该……但很多人都在质疑，他们打算怎么做？所以它本质上是一个盒子里的手机类型主板，你知道，然后这些控制器据说会很好。完美。所以他们甚至能够制造出……价格太低了吗？100 美元，我的意思是这比任何其他，你知道，我的意思是微软，Xbox 我猜
is like $140 maybe or $200 on the low end or something like that, I mean it's up there and that's like they've sold loads and loads and huge economies of scale to get down to that price so it'll be interesting to see what Ou are tries to sell the you know once it goes commercial like once they're selling on their website or whatever what it'll
可能是 140 美元，或者低端 200 美元左右，我的意思是它很高，而且他们已经卖了很多很多，巨大的规模经济才达到那个价格。所以看看 OUYA 在它商业化之后，比如一旦他们在他们的网站上销售它，它会卖多少钱，这会很有趣。
sell for will they be able to keep the $99 price point if so might be good traction and then how many people need to be on the OUYA for it to be an ecosystem worthy of targeting yeah so like you're a developer for iPhone right now. Like, how many people, you're not going to convert everybody, so how many people need to be on the platform for you to spend, you know, however much time of your own money to port it to their system? Yeah, exactly. Yeah, it makes sense.
它会卖多少钱？他们能保持 99 美元的价位吗？如果能，可能会有很好的吸引力。然后需要有多少人在 OUYA 上，它才能成为一个值得瞄准的生态系统？是的，就像你现在是 iPhone 的开发者。我的意思是，有多少人，你不可能转化所有人，所以需要有多少人在平台上，你才会花，你知道，你自己的钱花多少时间把它移植到他们的系统上？是的，完全正确。是的，这很有道理。
You really have to get that critical mass to get the developers online and everything. Yeah, but, I mean, they've raised a ton, like $5 million, right? Yeah, it's insane. $5.4 million. You and I mean, they've raised a ton of money, like $5 million, right? Yeah, it's insane. $5.4 million. You and I need to come up with a video game console. We need to make, we need to make this app
你真的必须获得那个临界质量才能让开发者上线等等。是的，但是，我的意思是，他们筹集了很多钱，比如 500 万美元，对吧？是的，这太疯狂了。540 万美元。你和我的意思是，他们筹集了很多钱，比如 500 万美元，对吧？是的，这太疯狂了。540 万美元。你和我需要想出一个电子游戏机。我们需要制作，我们需要制作这个应用程序
for this console. There you go, a game for the Ouya. Yeah, yeah, the, you know, you have to do something all day game. Oh, the one we're talking about.
为这个游戏机。给你，一个为 OUYA 制作的游戏。是的，是的，你知道，你必须整天做点什么游戏。哦，我们正在谈论的那个。
Yeah, maybe we will. All right. In all that spare time that we have. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So right. In all that spare time that we have. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So this next article is, is C and or C++ worth it? And I thought this was a really fascinating article.
是的，也许我们会。好的。在我们拥有的所有空闲时间里。是的，完全正确。是的。所以下一篇文章是，C 和/或 C++ 值得吗？我觉得这是一篇非常迷人的文章。
You know, just to get to the meat of the article, they say, no, it's not worth it for almost everything. And they show Java as an example. But yeah, I mean, one thing that I noticed the article doesn't talk about is memory layout. So the example that the article gave is they ran through a loop, ran through an array, and then added the previous element of the array to the current one. So it was a simple array add operation. But I mean, where a language like C or C++ really shines is in laying out this memory model, either beforehand or laying out a memory model that's very efficient. And then working within that model.
你知道，为了切入文章的重点，他们说，不，对于几乎所有事情来说，它都不值得。他们以 Java 为例。但是，是的，我的意思是，我注意到文章没有谈论的一件事是内存布局。所以文章给出的例子是他们运行了一个循环，遍历了一个数组，然后将数组的前一个元素加到当前元素上。所以这是一个简单的数组加法操作。但是，我的意思是，像 C 或 C++ 这样的语言真正闪光的地方在于布局这种内存模型，要么提前布局，要么布局一个非常高效的内存模型。然后在该模型内工作。
And so I feel like the article wasn't very holistic, but it's still a really interesting read. It's cool that Java actually outperforms C++ in this test case and many different compilers and things like that. That's cool. We'll talk a little bit more about Java performance in our section to come. But I always see these, and I'm always a little doubtful, because you really need a whole benchmark suite of really orthogonal tests. Because we can probably find any number of things at which any language is faster than any other language.
所以我感觉这篇文章不是很全面，但它仍然是一篇非常有趣的读物。Java 在这个测试案例和许多不同的编译器等中实际上表现优于 C++，这很酷。我们会谈论更多关于 Java 性能的内容，在接下来的部分。但我总是看到这些，我总是有点怀疑，因为你真的需要一套完整的真正正交测试的基准测试套件。因为我们可能找到任何数量的测试，在这些测试中任何语言都比任何其他语言快。
If you have the whole search space of potential algorithms or simple programs, you just try one until it beats the language you're trying to beat and you go, oh, I found it, you know, here. And it's like, yeah, I mean, you can spend time optimizing for any one thing. But what I want to know is like, on average, if I just throw a random problem or I know this is my typical domain set, how does one language perform against another? Yeah, totally. And this, I don't know, this article is actually, you know, pretty short. I mean, it is interesting that, you know, the typical Java slower than C++ thing at
如果你有潜在算法或简单程序的整个搜索空间，你只是尝试一个，直到它击败你试图击败的语言，然后你说，哦，我找到了，你知道，在这里。就像，是的，我的意思是，你可以花时间优化任何一件事。但我想要知道的是，平均而言，如果我只是抛出一个随机问题，或者我知道这是我的典型领域集，一种语言相对于另一种语言表现如何？是的，完全正确。而且这个，我不知道，这篇文章实际上，你知道，很短。我的意思是，有趣的是，你知道，典型的 Java 比 C++ 慢的事情在
this low-level task doesn't apply in this situation. Yeah, I mean, one thing to sort of take away is that, you know, these arguments of, oh, Java is really slow, like, you can't do this in Java because Java is slow. Like, that argument isn't true, right? of, oh, Java is really slow. You can't do this in Java because Java is slow. That argument isn't true. Worst case, let's say Java is 2 or 4x slower. For almost any application
这个低级任务中并不适用。是的，我的意思是，可以从中得出的一件事是，你知道，这些争论，哦，Java 真的很慢，就像，你不能在 Java 中做这个，因为 Java 很慢。就像，那个争论不是真的，对吧？哦，Java 真的很慢。你不能在 Java 中做这个，因为 Java 很慢。那个争论不是真的。最坏的情况，假设 Java 慢 2 或 4 倍。对于几乎任何应用程序
that would be fine. A lot of times you hear people say, oh, I can't use Java. It's too slow. I have to do this in C. That doesn't really... For almost any application, that doesn't make sense. But yeah, at the same time, this very simple example also
那都没问题。很多时候你听到人们说，哦，我不能使用 Java。它太慢了。我必须用 C 来做这个。那真的不……对于几乎任何应用程序，那都没有意义。但是，是的，同时，这个非常简单的例子也
doesn't prove anything either. DAN GALPINERIRIEFFENBERGERIRAHIMIRABINIRABINIRA. It's interesting. And it's always interesting to read the comments on these articles and see all the crazy optimizations people suggest. And you're crazy, go away. And all the way to very well-written, oh, actually, if you wanted this suits Java better
什么也证明不了。DAN GALPINERIRIEFFENBERGERIRAHIMIRABINIRABINIRA。这很有趣。阅读这些文章的评论并看到人们建议的所有疯狂优化总是很有趣。你疯了，走开。一直到写得很好的，哦，实际上，如果你想让这更适合 Java
to suit C++ better, you would do it like this and nuances of various things. It is an intriguing read, and sometimes you do learn some really nifty tricks that gurus in any language tend to know about their language. What is it, Donald Knuth quote in The Art of Programming, right,
更适合 C++，你会这样做，以及各种细微差别。这是一篇引人入胜的读物，有时你确实会学到一些任何语言的大师往往知道的关于他们语言的非常巧妙的技巧。唐纳德·克努特在《计算机程序设计艺术》中的那句名言是什么，对吧，
that early optimization is the root of all evil? Yeah. I'm summarizing. Pretty much your optimization. There we go, okay. I found out, sorry to interject, I found out Donald Knuth and I go to the same optometrist. What?
过早优化是万恶之源？是的。我正在总结。基本上你的优化。好了，好的。我发现，抱歉打断一下，我发现唐纳德·克努特和我去看同一个验光师。什么？
Yeah. Can I switch optometrists? You could totally go to this optometrist. Can you, like, ask for an appointment that's, you know how, like, you have to have your eyes dilated and you have to wait in the waiting room for a while? Yeah. Can, like, I ask for my appointment waiting to be, like like right when he's getting his eyes dilated so that i can
是的。我可以换验光师吗？你完全可以去这个验光师那里。你能，比如，要求一个预约，你知道，就像，你必须散瞳，你必须在候诊室等一会儿？是的。我可以要求我的预约等待时间，比如，就在他散瞳的时候，这样我就可以
talk to him you could accept now these guys are on this uh what is it um optiplex or something the thing where they take like that image oh yes you can't do it but maybe you could get it to where like you find out when his appointment is, and then you just show up. And you're, like, in the waiting room. I think I'll get, like, a restraining order. So, okay, we got a little off topic. But, yeah, so that is cool. Congratulations.
和他谈谈？你可以接受，现在这些人都在这个，嗯，它是什么，嗯，Optiplex 或类似的东西，他们拍摄图像的东西。哦，是的，你不能那样做，但也许你可以做到，比如你找出他的预约时间，然后你就直接出现。而且你，就像，在候诊室。我想我会得到，比如，限制令。所以，好吧，我们有点跑题了。但是，是的，所以这很酷。恭喜。
Yeah, you should totally go to this off topic. It's a pretty cool guy, too. Okay, I'll have to get that from you later. Yeah. So the next article is, I thought this was very interesting, engineering jellyfish. So some researchers kind of grew, made jellyfish out of a combination of plastic, and they grew some muscle on top of it and wrapped parts. So I think it's interesting.
是的，你应该完全去这个跑题。他也是个很酷的人。好的，我以后得从你那里得到那个。是的。所以下一篇文章是，我觉得这非常有趣，工程水母。所以一些研究人员培育了，用塑料组合制造了水母，他们在上面培育了一些肌肉并包裹了部件。所以我认为这很有趣。
Now, as far as what they managed to accomplish, did they create life? Well, I mean, they used some existing cells, so no. And also, they tuned everything to behave to the materials they had at hand. Like, they knew these cells act this way in this solution. So then they kind of engineered the whole thing to do it. But it is still kind of cool that they managed to make this star-shaped device which flexes and kind of, if you've ever seen a jellyfish move, kind of like balloon and squeeze out the water to move forward, which isn't efficient.
现在，至于他们设法完成了什么，他们创造了生命吗？嗯，我的意思是，他们使用了一些现有的细胞，所以没有。而且，他们调整了一切以适应他们手头的材料。就像，他们知道这些细胞在这种溶液中是这样表现的。所以他们就设计了整个东西来做到这一点。但它仍然很酷，他们设法制造了这个星形的装置，它会弯曲，如果你见过水母移动，就像气球一样，挤出水来向前移动，这并不高效。
It isn't the most supreme way of moving. It isn't really fast. But it's kind of cool that they're able to kind of get these, you know, things to move in a way that really resembles. And I always think that's interesting, this clashing of, and this one doesn't have a lot of, you know, it doesn't have a microprocessor or anything in it. But there was another article recently about the people who programmed a robotic fish, which got accepted by the school of fish or whatever. Oh, really? And so like they thought it was able to like lead it at one point. Wow, that's awesome. So I think this is kind of cool as we kind of learn more and more about animals
这不是最顶级的移动方式。它真的不快。但很酷的是，他们能够让这些，你知道，东西以一种非常相似的方式移动。我总是认为这很有趣，这种碰撞，而且这个没有很多，你知道，它没有微处理器什么的。但最近还有另一篇文章，关于那些编程了一个机器鱼的人，它被鱼群接受了什么的。哦，真的吗？所以就像他们认为它能够像在某一点上引导它一样。哇，那太棒了。所以我认为这很酷，因为我们越来越多地了解动物
and what we can take from the animal kingdom and say like, oh, you know, this is – even from – you always see those videos of people trying to fly like birds and putting wings on their arms and trying to do this kind of stuff. Even today we're kind of – people will look back on this jellyfish and say the same – well, maybe not this jellyfish, but these kinds of endeavors, right? Like, and kind of say the same thing. Oh, these people are trying to. Yeah, I think that, like, there's some domains where even just the simplest animal is so much better than our most sophisticated computers, right?
以及我们可以从动物王国中汲取什么，并说，哦，你知道，这是——甚至从——你总是看到那些人们试图像鸟一样飞翔，在手臂上装上翅膀并试图做这类事情的视频。即使在今天，我们也在某种程度上——人们会回顾这个水母并说同样的话——好吧，也许不是这个水母，而是这类努力，对吧？就像，并说同样的话。哦，这些人正在尝试。是的，我认为，就像，有些领域即使是最简单的动物也比我们最复杂的计算机好得多，对吧？
I mean, look at, like, image recognition or whatever. You know, a dog is just better than a supercomputer. Right. And so all of these attempts to sort of like integrate, you know, what we know of computing and and processing with, you know, the animal world and sort of how the brain works is is interesting because as we sort of bridge that gap, I think we'll learn a lot on both fronts. We'll learn more about neuroscience, and we'll also learn more about computation. And I guess I find intriguing this, I don't know, what is it, cyborg-type stuff.
我的意思是，看看，比如，图像识别什么的。你知道，狗就是比超级计算机好。对。所以所有这些试图整合，你知道，我们所知道的计算和处理与，你知道，动物世界以及大脑如何工作的方式，都是有趣的，因为当我们弥合那个差距时，我认为我们会在两个方面学到很多。我们会学到更多关于神经科学的知识，我们也会学到更多关于计算的知识。而且我猜我发现这很吸引人，我不知道，它是什么，赛博格类型的东西。
You know, you see these things where people put microcontrollers on the back of cockroaches and control them, and people insert brain inserts. I mean, all these kinds of things are so cool, being able to bring stuff that much closer. Originally, computers were in a giant room and couldn't go with you.
你知道，你看到这些东西，人们把微控制器放在蟑螂背上并控制它们，人们插入大脑插件。我的意思是，所有这些东西都太酷了，能够把东西拉得那么近。最初，计算机在一个巨大的房间里，不能和你一起走。
Then now everybody carries around very powerful computers in their pocket. And then maybe soon on their glasses. So always getting closer and closer and closer. And those things are just kind of exciting and cool. And the rate at which we're progressing is just kind of astonishing yeah yeah i mean i think that it would still be a long time before we have what is it called strong ai i think that's the term so strong ai means uh basically that it would pass the turing test for for day-to-day activities like that's like strong
然后现在每个人都在口袋里带着非常强大的计算机。然后也许很快就在他们的眼镜上。所以总是越来越近，越来越近。而那些事情只是有点令人兴奋和酷。而且我们进步的速度只是有点令人惊讶。是的，是的，我的意思是，我认为距离我们拥有什么，它叫强人工智能，我认为那是那个术语，还需要很长时间。所以强人工智能意味着，嗯，基本上它会通过图灵测试，对于日常活动，就像那是强
ai so i think we're still really far from that right but i think that that means that there's just it's just a completely open area and yeah and uh if you can make progress there's just so many different fronts in which you can make progress like vision is probably the one that's been explored the most but think about even just like muscle mechanics right like your uh your muscles are just a bunch of thin fibers that are put together but yet a robot has just a single joint motor yeah and so like why why isn't a robot knee more like a human knee where it's like like hundreds of these tendons that move together you know why is it just a hinge joint and so i
人工智能。所以我认为我们距离那个还真的很远，对吧？但我认为这意味着这只是一个完全开放的领域，是的，而且，嗯，如果你能取得进展，有太多不同的战线可以取得进展，比如视觉可能是探索最多的一个，但想想即使只是像肌肉力学，对吧？就像你的，嗯，你的肌肉只是一堆放在一起的细纤维，但机器人却只有一个关节电机。是的，所以就像为什么，为什么机器人膝盖不像人类膝盖那样，就像数百个这些肌腱一起移动，你知道，为什么它只是一个铰链关节？所以我
mean like i think all of these are interesting questions. And maybe this jellyfish makeup is a step in that direction, right? Yeah, I mean, that is true. Even if you had really good AI today, I mean, we still don't have a vessel to put it in that would allow it to really act like a human. It would be obvious. They don't move. They're not capable. Bipedal robots of today aren't really capable of moving in a way that fools you into thinking it's human.
我的意思是，我认为所有这些都是有趣的问题。也许这个水母化妆是朝着那个方向迈出的一步，对吧？是的，我的意思是，那是真的。即使你今天有非常好的 AI，我的意思是，我们仍然没有一个容器可以把它放进去，让它真正像人类一样行动。那会很明显。它们不动。它们没有能力。今天的双足机器人并没有真正具备以一种让你误以为它是人类的方式移动的能力。
And even if they are, they're typically either tethered or have a short battery life or, you know, aren't a full torso. Just all these limitations. So I wonder if it will end up being one of those things like, you know, we talk about processing speed has outstripped, you know, kind of batteries. That our batteries just haven't been able to keep up with how much power we need to be able to to run mobile devices the growths just don't match and that's i wonder if it'll be the same thing that we'll look back and see how we've gotten better and better at having machines that can do more but then like just nothing to put them in
即使它们有，它们通常要么被拴住，要么电池寿命短，或者，你知道，不是一个完整的躯干。只是所有这些限制。所以我不知道它最终是否会成为那种事情，就像，你知道，我们谈论处理速度已经超过了，你知道，电池。我们的电池只是无法跟上我们需要多少电力来运行移动设备，增长只是不匹配，而且我不知道它是否会是同样的事情，我们会回顾并看到我们如何变得越来越好，拥有可以做更多的机器，但然后就像没有什么可以把它们放进去。
yeah exactly everybody in other words everybody can't go into computer science yeah we need some of you mechanical engineers and biologists and neuroscientists. We need you guys too. Yep. I think it's time for Tool of the Buy Week. Tool of the Buy Week. All right, my tool is a set of three tools. Wait, that's cheating.
是的，完全正确。换句话说，每个人都不能去学计算机科学。是的，我们需要你们中的一些机械工程师、生物学家和神经科学家。我们也需要你们。是的。我想是时候进行本周工具了。本周工具。好的，我的工具是一套三个工具。等等，那是作弊。
It's totally cheating. Now you're just making it so you can look better than me. But they're all basically the same. And I'll talk about all three of them briefly so so I'll talk about the Windows ones first basically all three of these tools have the same purpose which is to bring the awesomeness of like Unix and like all the cool packages and the GNU packages that people have made and bring those over into other operating systems so sigwin which actually i think is short for like cygnus windows which is like cygnus is the company that i think is now bankrupt or something
这完全是作弊。现在你只是让它变得让你看起来比我好。但它们基本上是一样的。我会简要谈谈所有这三个，所以我先谈谈 Windows 的那些。基本上这三个工具都有相同的目的，就是把 Unix 的那种牛逼，以及人们制作的所有酷包和 GNU 包，带到其他操作系统中。所以 Cygwin，我实际上认为它是 Cygnus Windows 的缩写，就像 Cygnus 是那家公司，我想现在已经破产了什么的
but they made this is actually uh what's called posix so a little bit of history um unix runs on top of this thing called posix which is or maybe posix runs on unix this thing called POSIX which is or maybe POSIX runs on Unix I don't quite know this all happened way before either of us were born but essentially POSIX is the thing that implements a lot of the functionality of Unix like fork which is a function which
但他们制作了这个，实际上是，嗯，所谓的 POSIX，所以一点历史，嗯，Unix 运行在这个叫 POSIX 的东西之上，它是，或者也许 POSIX 运行在 Unix 上，这个叫 POSIX 的东西，它是，或者也许 POSIX 运行在 Unix 上，我不太清楚，这一切都发生在我们出生之前很久，但本质上 POSIX 是实现 Unix 很多功能的东西，比如 fork，它是一个函数，它
you know takes your process and splits it into two processes while keeping all the variables in both processes so it like makes a copy of it so all these like very primitive functions that comprise like the unix layer right above the operating system right above the kernel so that posix someone went ahead and implemented that by using windows calls so when you, Cygwin turns that into like a Unix, or sorry, like a Windows, like the create thread function and then copies
你知道，获取你的进程并将其拆分为两个进程，同时在两个进程中保留所有变量，所以它就像制作了一个副本。所以所有这些非常原始的函数，构成了像 Unix 层，就在操作系统之上，就在内核之上。所以那个 POSIX，有人继续并使用 Windows 调用实现了它。所以当你，Cygwin 把那个变成像 Unix，或者抱歉，像 Windows，就像创建线程函数，然后复制
over all the variables manually or something like that. So they implemented all the POSIX routines in Windows and then once they did that, now for programs that are built on Unix like GTK for example, they will just compile on Cygwin because they don't know any better. The functions just do what they're supposed to, and to these higher-level programs, it just works. Which is a beauty of something like POSIX. If you really restrict, here's, in essence, an API you're programming against, how strong that can really be.
手动覆盖所有变量或类似的东西。所以他们在 Windows 中实现了所有的 POSIX 例程，然后一旦他们这样做了，现在对于在 Unix 上构建的程序，比如 GTK，它们就会在 Cygwin 上编译，因为它们不知道任何更好的。这些函数只是做它们应该做的事情，对于这些更高级别的程序，它只是工作。这是像 POSIX 这样的东西的美妙之处。如果你真的限制，这里，本质上是一个你正在编程的 API，那可以有多强大。
Yeah, totally. So Cygwin is awesome. And there is one problem with SigWin, which is, you know, you have this POSIX code, and it's wrapped in what's called the SigWin1.dll. And, you know, as I mentioned, all of the code calls functions in this wrapper, in this intermediary layer. So let's say I was to make a program with Cygwin, like Jason's program, and I wanted to give it to Patrick. I also have to give him the Cygwin1.dll, which doesn't sound like that big a deal, but there's actually a license restriction.
是的，完全正确。所以 Cygwin 很棒。但 Cygwin 有一个问题，就是你有一段 POSIX 代码，它被封装在一个叫 Cygwin1.dll 的东西里。正如我提到的，所有的代码都调用这个封装器（即中间层）中的函数。假设我用 Cygwin 编写了一个程序，比如 Jason 的程序，我想把它给 Patrick。我还必须给他 Cygwin1.dll，这听起来没什么大不了的，但实际上有一个许可限制。
The Cygwin1.dll is GPL. So which means if I was to give Patrick Jason's program, I also have to give him the source code. And so, that can cause issues, you know, depending on your environment and things like that. The other issue that I've run into before with Sigwin is that although it's great to cross-compile and it works really well, like, it's an amazing tool and it helps a lot of things, is that you can end up with trickiness.
Cygwin1.dll 是 GPL 协议的。这意味着如果我把 Jason 的程序给 Patrick，我也必须给他源代码。这可能会导致一些问题，具体取决于你的环境等等。我在 Cygwin 上遇到的另一个问题是，虽然它非常适合交叉编译，而且工作得很好，它是一个了不起的工具，帮了很多忙，但你最终可能会遇到一些棘手的情况。
You think you're running in Linux sometimes. And so, if a program is doing something which normally takes 10 milliseconds in Linux, but it might, because of all the extra work that has to be done in Windows to simulate it, it might take 10 seconds or something crazy. You can end up with programs that are just completely unusable or just take a really long time. Because, for instance, Fork in Linux
有时候你会以为自己在 Linux 下运行。所以，如果一个程序在 Linux 下通常需要 10 毫秒，但在 Windows 下，由于需要进行额外的模拟工作，它可能需要 10 秒或者更离谱的时间。你最终得到的程序可能完全无法使用，或者运行速度极慢。因为，例如，Linux 中的 Fork
is a completely different kind of operation than creating a new process in Windows. Yeah, you're totally right. So in general, so let me get to the alternative signal, which is called MinGW, which I think is Minimalist GNU for Windows. And MinGW is similar, but it actually works on the compiler level. So what that means is, you you know I write my code I have access to all these cool posix functions but then what they do is that compile
与 Windows 中创建新进程的操作完全不同。是的，你说得完全对。那么总的来说，让我来介绍一下替代方案，叫做 MinGW，我认为它是 Minimalist GNU for Windows 的缩写。MinGW 很相似，但它实际上是在编译器层面工作的。这意味着，你知道，我编写代码，可以使用所有这些很酷的 POSIX 函数，但他们所做的是在编译
time they dump it all together into an executable that completely is self-sufficient so you don't need the sigwin DLL it's not main GW isn't GPL so you're not like you you're okay there. And in general, the executables are faster. So the bad thing about Ming GW is it doesn't have this package manager. Like with Sigwin, you could just run the Sigwin package manager and say, I want GTK, and it'll do everything. A couple of clicks, now you have GTK. Ming GW is more of a compiler, so it's not
时将它们全部打包成一个完全自给自足的可执行文件，所以你不需要 Cygwin DLL。MinGW 不是 GPL 协议的，所以你在这方面没问题。总的来说，可执行文件运行得更快。MinGW 的缺点是它没有包管理器。就像 Cygwin，你可以直接运行 Cygwin 包管理器说“我想要 GTK”，它就会完成所有工作。点几下，你就有了 GTK。MinGW 更像是一个编译器，所以它并不是
really meant for that kind of thing. In general, use Cygwin when you want to run Unix programs and use Ming GW when you want to make programs from the Unix libraries. Yeah, that's the way I kind of use it. So that's for Windows. Now, for Mac people, don't feel left out.
真正为那种事情设计的。总的来说，当你想要运行 Unix 程序时使用 Cygwin，当你想要用 Unix 库制作程序时使用 MinGW。是的，我就是这样用的。所以这是 Windows 的情况。现在，对于 Mac 用户，不要觉得被冷落了。
You can totally use GNU programs. You can totally use your GNU Cache and GNU Chess and GNU Go and all those cool things and Inkscape and GIMP and whatever by using MacPorts. And so MacPorts is a... Jeez, how would you describe MacPorts. And so MacPorts is, jeez, how would you describe MacPorts? So I think it's a little bit of a fundamentally different thing than what happens on Windows because Windows isn't really based at all on a Linux-type POSIX environment, whereas OSX kind of is. So OSX is just kind of providing the right kind of compliant libraries to kind of get at.
你完全可以使用 GNU 程序。你可以完全使用你的 GNU Cache、GNU Chess、GNU Go 以及所有那些很酷的东西，还有 Inkscape、GIMP 等等，通过使用 MacPorts。MacPorts 是一个……天哪，你会怎么描述 MacPorts 呢？所以 MacPorts 是……天哪，你会怎么描述 MacPorts？我认为它与 Windows 上发生的事情有着本质上的不同，因为 Windows 并不是真正基于 Linux 类型的 POSIX 环境，而 OSX 某种程度上是。所以 OSX 只是提供了一种正确的兼容库来获取。
This is my understanding. I'm probably messing this up. No, I think that's right. Get at the understanding that underlies. Like here's how to do the thing you would do in Linux but on OSX. Yeah, I think that's exactly right. So Mac ports is basically just changes to like build systems and things like that, which are sort of Mac-specific. And it sort of takes into account the fact that some things already exist on Mac because it's also a POSIX-compliant system,
这是我的理解。我可能搞错了。不，我认为那是对的。理解其背后的逻辑。就像这里是如何在 OSX 上做你在 Linux 下会做的事情。是的，我认为这完全正确。所以 MacPorts 基本上只是对构建系统等进行了一些更改，这些更改是 Mac 特有的。它考虑到了某些东西在 Mac 上已经存在的事实，因为它也是一个符合 POSIX 标准的系统，
but then some other things don't exist or have to be rebuilt or something like that. I guess the other thing is making sure that the right libraries are there because it doesn't natively know how a Mac doesn't natively know how to get all of the right libraries associated with it. So you kind of need a way to say, hey, I need to go grab all these extra libraries that didn't ship with my computer. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
但有些其他东西不存在，或者必须重新构建之类的。我想另一件事是确保有正确的库，因为它本身不知道如何获取所有相关的正确库。所以你需要一种方法说：“嘿，我需要去获取所有那些没有随我的电脑一起提供的额外库。”是的，完全正确。是的。
So yeah, these are great. If you use Windows, you should definitely be using Sigwin. If you're a Mac guy, definitely check out MacPorts. If nothing else, it's fun to use these programs and just browse through all the packages. Because there could be some really interesting tools that you've never heard of or maybe new programming languages that you want to try that are already there that you just couple of clicks and you can get them on your computer. And I should probably correct myself before we get lots of not happy email
所以，是的，这些都很棒。如果你使用 Windows，你绝对应该使用 Cygwin。如果你是 Mac 用户，一定要看看 MacPorts。至少，使用这些程序并浏览所有软件包是很有趣的。因为可能有一些你从未听说过的非常有趣的工具，或者你可能想尝试的新编程语言，它们已经在那里了，只需点击几下，你就可以把它们安装到你的电脑上。我应该在收到大量不满的邮件之前纠正自己，
about saying OSX has Linux underneath. And this is where I'll show my, it's really BSD. Oh, really? So I think OSX has BSD underneath it. And even then there's some other squirrely stuff. So please just like anything that was said in the last, it wasn't quite right, just please forgive us, or forgive me anyways.
关于说 OSX 底层是 Linux。这就是我露怯的地方，它实际上是 BSD。哦，真的吗？所以我认为 OSX 底层是 BSD。即便如此，还有一些其他奇怪的东西。所以，请原谅我们在上一段中说的任何不太正确的话，或者至少原谅我。
That's our first mistake ever. Man, that's a milestone mistake number one. Yeah, number one. Yeah. So my tool of the bi-week is far less technical than that. So you share. And I have a Google TV, a Logitech review at home. And I had some movie files on my
这是我们有史以来第一次犯错。天哪，这是一个里程碑式的错误。是的，第一个。是的。所以我的双周工具比那个技术含量低得多。所以你分享。我家里有一个 Google TV，一个罗技 Revue。我有一些电影文件在我的
computer and I wanted to stream from one to the other because my my computer is hooked up to my small monitor in one room and I have a nice TV in the other room and the Google TV is hooked up to that and of course Google TV works great for playing Netflix and other stuff and they, and this is true of many now actually TVs themselves and things like we talked about last week about Xbox Media Center, even running on an Apple TV, that you have the ability to stream from a DLNA server. And so I tried to get various DLNA servers set up on my
电脑上，我想把它们从一台设备流式传输到另一台，因为我的电脑连接在另一个房间的小显示器上，而我在另一个房间有一台不错的电视，Google TV 就连在那上面。当然，Google TV 在播放 Netflix 和其他内容方面表现出色，而且，这对于现在许多电视本身以及我们上周谈到的 Xbox Media Center，甚至在 Apple TV 上运行的东西来说都是如此，你都有能力从 DLNA 服务器进行流式传输。所以我尝试在我的
computer, and I got some to work but most of them seemed to want to go into GUI mode, require lots of setup but I was able to get UShare installed so that I could kind of configure it and manage it over just SSH so that I didn't have to keep going into this computer that wasn't always plugged into a monitor and so now it worked
电脑上设置各种 DLNA 服务器，我让一些成功运行了，但大多数似乎都想进入 GUI 模式，需要大量的设置。但我能够安装 UShare，这样我就可以只通过 SSH 来配置和管理它，而不必一直去那台并不总是连接显示器的电脑上。所以现在它工作得
great, like just right out of the box. I mean it doesn't do a lot of the DLNA servers try to index your files and say, like, oh, here's movies with actor. I don't know an actor. Give me an acronym. Tom Hanks. Tom Hanks.
很好，就像开箱即用一样。我的意思是，它不做很多 DLNA 服务器尝试索引你的文件并说：“哦，这是有演员的电影。”我不知道一个演员。给我一个缩写。汤姆·汉克斯。汤姆·汉克斯。
Tom Hanks. You know, here's all the movies with Tom Hanks in them. And, like, let me go fetch all this extra data. That sounds cool, though. That would be cool if it worked. And then if it doesn't work, it kind of, like, seems like most of them just default into giving up or whatever. So I just wanted to have it fairly well structured in a
汤姆·汉克斯。你知道，这是所有有汤姆·汉克斯出演的电影。而且，让我去获取所有这些额外的数据。听起来很酷。如果它能工作的话会很酷。然后如果它不工作，看起来大多数服务器只是默认放弃或者其他什么。所以我只是想让它在我想要的
file folder structure that I wanted. And yousure has, I think, this other option to do this indexing and do awesomeness. But I didn't really want that. So I just turned it off and just like, please just give me so when I go onto my Google TV, I can navigate to the folders and then just select the video file I want, and then it does the transcoding for me. So because Google TV only does a very limited set of codecs, the Ushare knows how to convert it using, I think they use FFmpeg by default.
文件文件夹结构中结构良好。我想 UShare 有另一个选项可以进行这种索引并实现很棒的功能。但我并不真正想要那个。所以我只是把它关掉了，就像：“请只给我，这样当我进入我的 Google TV 时，我可以导航到文件夹，然后选择我想要的视频文件，然后它会为我进行转码。”因为 Google TV 只支持非常有限的一组编解码器，Ushare 知道如何使用（我想它们默认使用 FFmpeg）来转换它。
Convert it over for me so that it just plays, and then it's like, this is lovely. And it starts up really fast and goes smoothly, and I haven't had any issues or any files I came across yet that wouldn't play. And so that made me very happy. So that's why they get a recommendation from me that's you share nice so so just so i understand because my my media setup thing is a disaster i need you to come over it need to hire you like a time sink but so i have a desktop which has a bunch of movies on it uh in one room then i have a laptop connected to a monitor in the other room and right now I just do this painful like I'll copy the files over and then run them or I'll have like an NFS but it doesn't quite work right because it's not like a true media server so like
为我转换它，这样它就能播放了，这真是太棒了。它启动得非常快，运行也很流畅，我还没有遇到任何无法播放的文件。所以这让我非常高兴。这就是为什么他们得到了我的推荐，那就是 UShare。很好，所以为了让我理解，因为我的媒体设置简直是一场灾难，我需要你过来，我需要雇佣你，就像一个时间黑洞。但我有一台台式机，里面有一堆电影，在一个房间里；然后我有一台连接到显示器的笔记本电脑在另一个房间。现在我只是做这种痛苦的事情，比如我会把文件复制过去然后运行它们，或者我会像 NFS 一样，但它不太好用，因为它不是一个真正的媒体服务器，所以
there's all sorts of latency and sometimes a video stutters so you're saying I can install this on the desktop in the living room, which doesn't have anything attached to it. Right. And then the laptop, what would I install on the laptop? So on the laptop, there's all sorts of what you want is a UPnP or a DLNA client. So there's all sorts. I think VLC will even do this and connect up to it.
会有各种延迟，有时视频会卡顿。所以你是说我可以把它安装在客厅的台式机上，那台机器上什么都没连接。对。然后笔记本电脑，我应该在笔记本电脑上安装什么？所以在笔记本电脑上，你需要的是一个 UPnP 或 DLNA 客户端。所以有很多。我想 VLC 甚至可以做到这一点并连接到它。
And the nice thing is if you have a laptop, you actually shouldn't need to do any transcoding because your computer can play everything. So it'll know how to stream it. But the DLNA servers, and I believe you, Cher, will do this too, it'll also detect your link speed. So it knows, like, even if you understand the codec, if the rate is too high, it'll downcode it for you
而且好消息是，如果你有一台笔记本电脑，你实际上不需要进行任何转码，因为你的电脑可以播放所有内容。所以它知道如何流式传输它。但是 DLNA 服务器，我相信 UShare 也会这样做，它也会检测你的链路速度。所以它知道，即使你理解编解码器，如果速率太高，它也会为你进行降码，
so that it can stream reliably across the network. Wow, this is amazing. I mean, this is stuff that's done all the time for YouTube videos, for Netflix. I mean, this technology is out there. And it's just, you know, sometimes it's a little complicated to get set up. Yeah, yeah. And so I kind of ended up taking the shotgun approach and installing, like, five different, you know, UPnP servers
这样它就可以在网络上可靠地流式传输。哇，这太神奇了。我的意思是，这是 YouTube 视频、Netflix 一直在做的事情。我的意思是，这种技术是存在的。只是，你知道，有时设置起来有点复杂。是的，是的。所以我最终采取了“霰弹枪”方法，安装了大约五个不同的 UPnP 服务器，
and seeing which one would just work nice with my device. And then you use VLC as the client? So on mine, I have a Google TV. So Google TV has, like, a specific, like, here's the program you run. Or if you have a TV or the client? So on mine, I have a Google TV. So Google TV has like a specific, like here's the program you run. Or if you have a TV or an Xbox or a PlayStation 3, they all have like these are the program you go run and select the file you want to play and then it will stream it for you. But on a laptop, there's lots of them.
看看哪一个能和我的设备配合得很好。然后你用 VLC 作为客户端？在我的设备上，我有一个 Google TV。所以 Google TV 有一个特定的，比如，这是你运行的程序。或者如果你有一台电视或客户端？在我的设备上，我有一个 Google TV。所以 Google TV 有一个特定的，比如这是你运行的程序。或者如果你有一台电视或 Xbox 或 PlayStation 3，它们都有，比如这些是你去运行并选择你想播放的文件的程序，然后它会为你流式传输。但在笔记本电脑上，有很多这样的程序。
So like if you're running Windows, like Windows Media Center will do it or just Windows Movie Player. Windows. Okay. Whatever the Windows Movie Player thing is. Yeah, yeah. Or like I said, I think it's whatever the Windows movie player thing is. Yeah, yeah. But, you know, or like I said, I think VLC will do it. There's also Xbox Media Center, which we talked about last week, is a UPnP client as well.
所以如果你运行 Windows，Windows Media Center 会做这件事，或者只是 Windows Movie Player。Windows。好的。不管 Windows Movie Player 是什么东西。是的，是的。或者像我说的，我想不管 Windows Movie Player 是什么东西。是的，是的。但是，你知道，或者像我说的，我想 VLC 会做这件事。还有 Xbox Media Center，我们上周谈到过，它也是一个 UPnP 客户端。
And we'll give you the nice, what they call, 10-foot display. So the ones with the big words and not the normal file menus. So you can navigate with large categories and select it on your remote. Oh, that is totally cool. And then be able to play it that way. Nice. That is awesome. I'll have to check that out. So if it works, you'll have to report back and let be able to play it that way. Nice. That is awesome. I'll have to check that out.
它会给你提供他们所谓的“10 英尺显示界面”。也就是那些大字体的，而不是普通的文件菜单。所以你可以用遥控器通过大类别进行导航并选择它。哦，那太酷了。然后能够那样播放它。不错。那太棒了。我得去看看。如果它能用，你得回来报告一下，让能够那样播放它。不错。那太棒了。我得去看看。
So if it works, you'll have to report back and let us know. Yeah, next week. I'll try it this week. Or you can email me and say, oh, it's not working. What happened? So two weeks from now, either we won't have a podcast because Patrick hates me, or we'll be talking about how I got this media center set up. Anyway, check it out.
所以如果它能用，你得回来告诉我们。是的，下周。我这周会试试。或者你可以给我发邮件说：“哦，它没用。发生了什么？”所以两周后，要么我们没有播客了，因为 Patrick 讨厌我，要么我们会谈论我是如何设置这个媒体中心的。总之，去看看吧。
That's you share. Yeah, it looks awesome. Yeah, I'll definitely do that. Folks at home should, too. Time for Java. Java. This is like trying to swing a sledgehammer. I mean, we probably won't be able to cover
那就是 UShare。是的，看起来很棒。是的，我一定会那样做的。家里的听众也应该这样做。Java 时间。Java。这就像试图挥动大锤。我的意思是，我们可能无法涵盖
everything. Yeah, I think we already agree. We're going to call this Java Part 0.0.1. Java Micro Edition. So this is going to be an introduction. We're not going to try to cover everything. And we know we'll come back and revisit some more of these things later. So Java kind of has an interesting history. I mean, everything has an interesting history, I guess, if history is interesting to you.
所有内容。是的，我想我们已经同意了。我们要把这称为 Java 0.0.1 版本。Java Micro Edition。所以这将是一个介绍。我们不会试图涵盖所有内容。我们知道我们以后会回来重新审视其中一些内容。所以 Java 有一段有趣的历史。我的意思是，如果历史对你来说很有趣的话，我想每件事都有有趣的历史。
The interesting thing about Java is that the history was, like, when we were sort of learning, when we were learning as much as possible about computer science, like, when we were learning more per month than ever, Java was like the language that's a good way to put it yeah it was like right in the sweet spot of for me like you know right when i was kind of getting to college java had just come out of its infancy yeah you know and it was like you know right when it first came out i didn't really know what's going on i didn't know i heard about it but then you know like as i began to get you know into late high school and college i began to see like people wanting to use java and think about java and talk about java yeah it was the hotness yeah yeah that's right the hotness
关于 Java 有趣的一点是，它的历史是，就像当我们某种程度上在学习时，当我们尽可能多地学习计算机科学时，就像当我们每月学习的东西比以往任何时候都多时，Java 就像是那种语言。这是一个很好的说法。是的，它正处于我的“甜蜜点”。你知道，就在我快上大学的时候，Java 刚刚走出它的婴儿期。是的，你知道，就在它刚出来的时候，我真的不知道发生了什么。我不知道，我听说过它，但后来，你知道，当我开始进入高中后期和大学时，我开始看到人们想要使用 Java，思考 Java，谈论 Java。是的，它是当时的热门。是的，是的，没错，热门。
so their their slogan which i think you know it's still kind of one of the best strong points which is amazing that we kind of take it for granted that somebody can set out to do something and then actually do it so java had this write once, run anywhere. That was like their slogan or whatever. And, you know, without getting into too much debate, it took them a while. But I think today, you know, regardless of everything, if you just ignore that, look at that motto from 1995 and then now like 2012 and you say like, hey, Java, where's it running? And Java runs on all sorts of platforms and devices.
所以他们的口号，我认为你知道，它仍然是最好的优点之一，这很神奇，我们认为某人可以着手做某事然后真正做到这一点是理所当然的。所以 Java 有这个“一次编写，到处运行”。这就是他们的口号之类的。而且，你知道，在不进行太多辩论的情况下，他们花了一些时间。但我认为今天，你知道，不管怎样，如果你忽略所有这些，看看 1995 年的那个座右铭，然后现在是 2012 年，你说：“嘿，Java，它在哪里运行？”Java 在各种平台和设备上运行。
And, you know, I don't know how much the right once part comes into that, but they really are, you know, making it so that it is so much more pervasive than a lot of other languages ever reach. Yeah, totally. Yeah, I mean, think about all the pain that goes into like deploying an app, you know?
而且，你知道，我不知道“一次编写”的部分在其中占了多少，但他们确实，你知道，让它变得比许多其他语言所能达到的要普及得多。是的，完全正确。是的，我的意思是，想想部署一个应用程序所带来的所有痛苦，你知道吗？
I mean, you have to deal with, you know, first you have to build it for every architecture and you have to deal with all these like 32 bit 64 bit issues you know if it's big indian little indians so not only do you have to build it for these different architectures but sometimes you have to change the code depending on which one um like god forbid you try to like you know mem copy a structure straight to a file or something because that'll never port over right so there's all these, like, you know, mem copy a structure straight to a file or something because that will never port over, right? So there's all these disasters. And then, you know, you finally get it to where the code is okay and the code runs the same on all these machines.
我的意思是，你必须处理，你知道，首先你必须为每个架构构建它，你必须处理所有这些 32 位 64 位的问题，你知道，如果是大端序、小端序。所以你不仅要为这些不同的架构构建它，有时你还必须根据不同的架构更改代码。嗯，天哪，如果你试图，你知道，把一个结构体直接内存拷贝到一个文件里或者其他什么，因为那永远无法移植，对吧？所以有所有这些，你知道，把一个结构体直接内存拷贝到一个文件里或者其他什么，因为那永远无法移植，对吧？所以有所有这些灾难。然后，你知道，你终于让代码没问题了，代码在所有这些机器上运行得一样。
Now you have to deal with, oh, this person is missing this library that you expected them to have installed. So now you have to carry over, like like a virtual machine, like virtual box or something that runs a completely bare bones Windows and run your program there and make sure that you don't have some DLL that you didn't realize you had that no one else has, right? So you have all this drama. With Java, you can, you know, using Eclipse or NetBeans or any of these IDs, these tools we'll talk about later, you can just click on your Java code and say, give me a runnable jar, which is, what is it, Java Archive or something?
现在你必须处理：“哦，这个人缺少你期望他们安装的库。”所以现在你必须携带，比如像一个虚拟机，像 VirtualBox 或其他什么，运行一个完全精简的 Windows，并在那里运行你的程序，并确保你没有一些你没意识到自己拥有的 DLL，而其他人都没有，对吧？所以你有所有这些戏剧性的事情。使用 Java，你可以，你知道，使用 Eclipse 或 NetBeans 或任何这些我们稍后会谈论的 IDE，这些工具，你可以直接点击你的 Java 代码并说：“给我一个可运行的 JAR”，也就是，它是什么，Java Archive 还是什么？
Sounds good. I'll look it up. You just say, hey, give me a package of, like, take this code and make it run on any machine I want. And it will do it. And you'll end up with this one file. You can give it to your friend as long as he has Java installed which now the install base is extremely high. He can just double click the file you gave him and it will work. And you're just bypassing all of the things that I mentioned before. So I mean this is huge.
听起来不错。我会查一下。你只是说：“嘿，给我一个包，比如，拿这段代码并让它在我想要的任何机器上运行。”它就会做到。你最终会得到这一个文件。你可以把它给你的朋友，只要他安装了 Java，现在安装基数非常高。他可以直接双击你给他的文件，它就能工作。你只是绕过了我之前提到的所有事情。所以我的意思是这非常巨大。
Now we take it for granted but at the time this was just incredible that you could do something like this. DAN GALPINIERI- Yeah, I feel like there's a lot of legacy that goes into Java. And whenever we talk about it, ultimately you kind of talk about it from one aspect. There's the individual programmer. There's the enterprise team. There's the person learning to program.
现在我们认为这是理所当然的，但在当时，你能做到这一点简直是不可思议。DAN GALPINIERI- 是的，我觉得 Java 中有很多遗留问题。每当我们谈论它时，最终你都会从一个方面谈论它。有个人程序员。有企业团队。有学习编程的人。
There's all these different things. And so you kind of have to take one view at a time. But a lot of early experiences of Java kind of maybe had some missteps or people have bad memories or bad taste or somebody who's really good at C++, Java looks so close to C++ in so many ways that you're kind of tempted to just do things the same old way.
有所有这些不同的东西。所以你必须一次采取一个视角。但很多 Java 的早期经验可能有一些失误，或者人们有糟糕的记忆或糟糕的品味，或者某个非常擅长 C++ 的人，Java 在很多方面看起来和 C++ 太像了，以至于你很想用同样的老方法做事。
And we talk about that a lot on this podcast that when you use one language and then go to another, you can bring a lot of really interesting things. But if you just try to shoehorn one to the other, like, here's my C++ code, I want to line for line, just copy it into Java. Well, you can't expect that it's going to be the greatest ever because you're not using it the way it's meant to be used. Yeah, totally.
我们在本播客中经常谈论这一点，当你使用一种语言然后转向另一种语言时，你可以带来很多非常有趣的东西。但如果你只是试图强行把一种语言套用到另一种语言上，比如：“这是我的 C++ 代码，我想逐行把它复制到 Java 中。”好吧，你不能指望它是最好的，因为你没有以它本应被使用的方式使用它。是的，完全正确。
And then one really cool feature of Java was this notion of applets. So Java in 1995, it's coming out. And this is right around the time, or at least I remember, the Internet was really coming into its own and really starting to get a hold and become a serious place that people did business on. And it was really becoming what kind of it is today. And so these applets were programs you could run in your browser.
然后 Java 的一个非常酷的功能是 Applet 的概念。所以 Java 在 1995 年问世。这大约是在那个时候，或者至少我记得，互联网真正开始崭露头角，真正开始占据一席之地，并成为人们开展业务的严肃场所。它真正成为了它今天的那种样子。所以这些 Applet 是你可以在浏览器中运行的程序。
Instead of having to even send your friend a JAR file, you could just host it on a server, and he could just go to this page and have the applet run. Yeah, I mean, and this is just mind-blowing, right? I mean, so this is before Flash, before any of that. So, I mean, basically you had either HTML or you had applets. I mean, that was pretty much it. I mean, you could do some clever things with like
你甚至不需要给你的朋友发送一个 JAR 文件，你只需要把它托管在服务器上，他就可以直接访问这个页面并运行 Applet。是的，我的意思是，这简直令人难以置信，对吧？我的意思是，这是在 Flash 之前，在所有这些之前。所以，我的意思是，基本上你要么有 HTML，要么有 Applet。我的意思是，基本上就是这样。我的意思是，你可以用像
css 1.0 or whatever so you could have like the font changing you know there was javascript tag yeah yeah you could do the blink tag there was like some basic things you could do with javascript but you know it was too slow i mean javascript is like 30x faster than it was back then so you couldn't really do anything fancy and uh and then applets came out and it was like oh my god i can do whatever i want like i can just draw pixels to the to the screen if i want on someone's website and that just like blew people's mind one of the most popular applets remember it was uh it was like you would give it some text and it would create this like reflection but the reflection was shaking as if it was like oh i don't think i've ever seen this yeah yeah that
CSS 1.0 之类的东西做一些聪明的事情，所以你可以改变字体，你知道，有 JavaScript 标签。是的，是的，你可以做 blink 标签，有一些你可以用 JavaScript 做的基本事情，但你知道，它太慢了。我的意思是，JavaScript 比当时快了 30 倍，所以你不能真正做任何花哨的事情。然后 Applet 出来了，就像：“哦，天哪，我可以做任何我想做的事，比如我可以在别人的网站上随意绘制像素。”这简直让人们大开眼界。记得最流行的 Applet 之一是，它会给你一些文本，然后它会创建这种反射，但反射在晃动，好像它是……哦，我想我从来没见过这个。是的，是的，那个
was like all these websites had this applet where it's just like the name of the website and then the name like inverted. It was kind of like I always felt like I had slow internet for a long time until I kind of went to college. And so like whenever I went to a page with Java, I knew it because it would just like take that much longer, you know, to load. But I think the other interesting thing that Java really addressed, and this might be me misremembering in nostalgia,
就像所有这些网站都有这个 Applet，它只是网站的名字，然后名字是倒置的。我总觉得我用了很长时间的慢速互联网，直到我上大学。所以每当我进入一个有 Java 的页面时，我就知道了，因为它加载起来需要那么长的时间，你知道吗？但我认为 Java 真正解决的另一件有趣的事情是，这可能是我记忆中的怀旧，
but, you know, because Java was, from the start, kind of heading towards the internet, had this applets, they really had to address security, you know, like, how do we really make things secure since the browser is going to let somebody run arbitrary code, just kind of like without permissions. They don't even have to download
但是，你知道，因为 Java 从一开始就有点朝着互联网发展，有这些 Applet，他们真的必须解决安全性问题，你知道，比如：“我们如何真正使事情安全，因为浏览器将允许某人运行任意代码，就像没有权限一样。”他们甚至不需要下载
something, you just go to a website, and all of a sudden code's kind of running and you know they've kind of iterated through that and done some stuff but really thinking about how do we have a good sense of security and how do we balance that with needing to access a person's computer but guarantee that those things we're doing are safe or allowed or okay yeah you know one interesting like side note so sgi did silicon graphics incorporated did like a bunch of like crazy pioneering graphics research like like when the so nintendo 64 when that came out um there was this weird thing it wasn't quite a triangle it was like a scan line like weird polygon thing and they were using that for doing like 3d rendering and it was like totally kind of crazy off the wall and then they they using that for doing like 3d rendering and it was like
什么东西，你只是访问一个网站，突然代码就开始运行了，你知道，他们已经迭代了这些并做了一些事情，但真正思考的是：我们如何拥有良好的安全感，以及我们如何平衡这一点与需要访问个人电脑的需求，但保证我们所做的事情是安全的、允许的或没问题的？是的，你知道一个有趣的旁注，SGI，即 Silicon Graphics Incorporated，做了很多疯狂的开创性图形研究，比如当 Nintendo 64 出来时，嗯，有一个奇怪的东西，它不完全是一个三角形，它就像一个扫描线，奇怪的多边形东西，他们用它来做 3D 渲染，这简直是完全疯狂的，然后他们用它来做 3D 渲染，这简直是
totally kind of crazy off the wall and then they they tried that they refined it then they switched to the polygon model they just all this pioneering research and then they died you know and it's sort of like this huge investment and the company dies uh or they got bought or something and i feel kind of bad because the same thing happened to Sun. It's like they made Java. They did all this cutting-edge pioneering, like groundbreaking stuff and then they just got bought like almost immediately. It's kind of like – Well, it wasn't exactly immediately. When did they get bought?
完全疯狂的，然后他们尝试了它，他们改进了它，然后他们切换到了多边形模型，他们做了所有这些开创性的研究，然后他们就死了，你知道，这就像这种巨大的投资，然后公司死了，或者他们被收购了之类的。我感觉有点糟糕，因为同样的事情也发生在 Sun 身上。就像他们创造了 Java。他们做了所有这些尖端的、开创性的、突破性的东西，然后他们几乎立即就被收购了。这就像——嗯，并不完全是立即。他们是什么时候被收购的？
It was fairly recently, right? So I mean I think they had a good about like 10 years, 15 years or something. Was it really that long? Yeah, and then Sun did a lot of other stuff as well, right? I think they might have existed before Java doing other things. Oh, really? We should have done, I guess, more research into Sun itself. But yeah, because they used to make server hardware and stuff as well.
那是相当近的时候，对吧？所以我的意思是，我认为他们大概有 10 年、15 年左右的时间。真的有那么久吗？是的，而且 Sun 也做了很多其他事情，对吧？我想他们在 Java 之前可能就存在并做其他事情了。哦，真的吗？我想我们应该对 Sun 本身做更多的研究。但是是的，因为他们过去也制造服务器硬件之类的东西。
Was that before or after Java? I don't know. Well, yeah, Solaris has been out forever, right? So, yeah. But even SGI has been out forever, right? So yeah, but, but even like SGI has been out forever too, but like the company's like, usually like, it seems like they come up with awesome stuff.
那是在 Java 之前还是之后？我不知道。嗯，是的，Solaris 已经存在很久了，对吧？所以，是的。但即使是 SGI 也存在很久了，对吧？所以是的，但即使像 SGI 也存在很久了，但就像公司一样，通常看起来他们想出了很棒的东西。
And then like a few years later, I don't know. I don't know why that is. Maybe, but sometimes that's a good thing, right? Like sometimes it means they did really well and somebody was willing to pay a lot of money for them.
然后几年后，我不知道。我不知道为什么会这样。也许，但有时这是一件好事，对吧？就像有时这意味着他们做得很好，有人愿意为他们支付很多钱。
Yeah, that's a good point. So, so that can happen. But yeah, so I mean, Java really did kind of was the first kind of mainstream language that addressed a lot of new paradigms as it were.
是的，这是一个很好的观点。所以，所以这可能会发生。但是是的，所以我的意思是，Java 确实是第一种解决了许多新范式的所谓主流语言。
You know, it kind of came out and it's like C++ had done the object-oriented thing. So like now Java is going to do it. Java is going to do it kind of in its own way and really embrace this, you know, object-oriented model and take it kind of to a new level and, you know, and really try to meet the needs of a lot of people. I mean, there are programming languages that did object-oriented arguably better in a different way. And a lot of them got acceptance in niche ways and kind of specific.
你知道，它出来的时候，就像 C++ 已经做了面向对象的事情。所以现在 Java 要做了。Java 要以它自己的方式做，并真正拥抱这个，你知道，面向对象的模型，并把它带到一个新的水平，你知道，并真正试图满足许多人的需求。我的意思是，有一些编程语言在不同方面做得更好，更具面向对象性。而且其中许多在利基市场和特定领域获得了认可。
But to make a mainstream acceptable programming language requires some compromises to try to meet everything that you are trying to do. And it's kind of amazing that Java was able to do that as well as it did. Yeah, totally. And the cool thing about Java is they kept it very close to C++ from a syntactic point of view. So you could think of it as a lower barrier of entry because a lot of the code looked the same. But they made sure it was sort of pure.
但要使一种主流可接受的编程语言需要一些妥协，以试图满足你正在尝试做的所有事情。而且 Java 能做得这么好，真是令人惊奇。是的，完全正确。而且 Java 的酷之处在于，从语法角度来看，他们让它非常接近 C++。所以你可以认为它是一个较低的进入门槛，因为很多代码看起来是一样的。但他们确保它是纯粹的。
You know, like C++, it's kind of clear that the object-oriented is built on top, right? And that C++ is sort of built on top of C. And it's like, it's sort of really evident. Like, for example, the way, like, callbacks are implemented in C++. Like, imagine if you, like, or, like, even, like, member function pointers. Like, if you want to have a function pointer
你知道，就像 C++，很明显面向对象是建立在顶部的，对吧？而且 C++ 是建立在 C 之上的。而且它，它真的很明显。例如，像 C++ 中实现回调的方式，想象一下如果你，或者，甚至像成员函数指针。如果你想有一个函数指针
to a method inside of a class in C++, that stuff's a disaster, right? Trying to do that is just a nightmare. Bang your head against the wall. It's because it's sort of C++ was sort of trying to do the whole classes thing, but still
指向 C++ 类中的一个方法，那些东西简直是一场灾难，对吧？尝试那样做简直是一场噩梦。撞墙。这是因为 C++ 某种程度上试图做整个类的事情，但仍然
interact completely transparently with C. And so by Java sort of separating itself from all that and saying we're not going to have these native arrays and all these things and just functions hanging out like global functions. We're not going to do that. By making these
与 C 完全透明地交互。所以通过 Java 将自己与所有这些分离开来，并说我们不会有这些原生数组和所有这些东西，以及像全局函数那样悬挂的函数。我们不会那样做。通过做出这些
restrictions and by making a brand new language, they were sort of able to make it a lot cleaner. Java also sticks out in my mind as coming out with updates. So I guess because C++ was kind of written, and it wasn't really a company that kind of owned it, right? This is our thing.
限制，并通过创造一种全新的语言，他们能够使它变得更干净。Java 在我脑海中也因为发布更新而脱颖而出。所以我想因为 C++ 是写出来的，而且并没有一个公司真正拥有它，对吧？这是我们的东西。
We're making it. It was good and bad. So Java came out. Sun owned it. They had made the virtual machines that the code. So we should talk about this a little. So in Java, the code compiles to, like something like a jar to you know these class files and these things are compiled against not your hardware but against the java virtual machine right the java virtual machine is written
我们在制作它。它有好有坏。所以 Java 出来了。Sun 拥有它。他们制作了代码运行的虚拟机。所以我们应该谈谈这个。在 Java 中，代码编译成，比如像 JAR，你知道这些类文件，这些东西不是针对你的硬件编译的，而是针对 Java 虚拟机编译的，对吧？Java 虚拟机是编写的
to basically run on your hardware and run the java program on that program on your hardware yeah so all those things i talked about before like the 3264 bit and the Big Indian, Little Indian, they dealt with that when they made the virtual machine. And so now you don't have to deal with that because you're sitting on top of like an abstraction. And so when they kind of made all of that, right? So like they owned the virtual machine in a way. They, you know, kind of defined the language.
基本上是在你的硬件上运行，并在你的硬件上运行 Java 程序。是的，所以我之前谈到的所有那些事情，比如 32/64 位和大端序、小端序，他们在制作虚拟机时处理了这些。所以现在你不需要处理这些，因为你坐在一个抽象层之上。所以当他们某种程度上制作了所有这些时，对吧？所以他们以某种方式拥有了虚拟机。他们，你知道，定义了语言。
They were able to make kind of updates, add features. And if you look at Java today, there's a lot of, like if you try to just compile a Java code written today against an early Java, I don't think it'll work. So much stuff has changed. And just even basic assumptions have changed over time and things have gotten optimized and better and adding new features and kind of working on the rough edges.
他们能够进行更新，添加功能。如果你看看今天的 Java，有很多，比如如果你试图编译今天编写的 Java 代码来对抗早期的 Java，我不认为它会工作。太多的东西改变了。甚至基本的假设也随着时间的推移而改变，事情得到了优化和改进，并添加了新功能，并处理了粗糙的边缘。
And I feel like they were able to do that because they could. Because they owned the stack in a way. But that didn't stop. In the licensing thing, we're not lawyers, so we're not going to really talk about it, because it gets really complicated and gets into it. But even from fairly early on, there were people who wrote other virtual machines.
我觉得他们能够做到这一点是因为他们可以。因为他们以某种方式拥有了堆栈。但这并没有停止。在许可方面，我们不是律师，所以我们不会真正谈论它，因为它变得非常复杂。但即使从相当早的时候开始，也有人编写了其他虚拟机。
So Java compiled to this bytecode. But if you could write a program that would interpret that bytecode and do stuff, go ahead. DAN GALPINIERI- Yeah, I saw something interesting the other day where someone wrote an LLVM, like interpreter for bytecode or something like that. Actually, it took in bytecode and it output C code. So it was like this Java to C compiler.
所以 Java 编译成这种字节码。但如果你能编写一个程序来解释该字节码并做事情，那就去做吧。DAN GALPINIERI- 是的，我前几天看到一些有趣的东西，有人编写了一个 LLVM，比如字节码解释器之类的。实际上，它接收字节码并输出 C 代码。所以它就像这个 Java 到 C 的编译器。
It was kind of crazy. DAN GALPINIERI- But I mean, yeah, the byte code is essentially machine code, assembly code, for a known virtual machine that isn't a real PC. And so that kind of concept in doing that, that's really intriguing, and people could do it. So in theory, if you think you can write a faster virtual machine than Java for a specific instance for your use
这有点疯狂。DAN GALPINIERI- 但我的意思是，是的，字节码本质上是机器码，汇编代码，用于一个不是真实 PC 的已知虚拟机。所以那种概念在做这件事，这真的很吸引人，人们可以做到。所以理论上，如果你认为你可以为你的特定用例编写一个比 Java 更快的虚拟机，
case, you could do that. And again, ignoring all of the licensing and problems and copyright, but this is what you hear about when people say Android runs on Java. So on your phone, when you run an Android program on an Android phone, it's not running on a Sun virtual machine. It's running on one that Google wrote that to the program kind of looks the same. Right.
你可以做到。而且再次忽略所有的许可、问题和版权，但这就是当人们说 Android 在 Java 上运行时你听到的。所以当你在手机上运行 Android 程序时，它不是在 Sun 虚拟机上运行。它是在 Google 编写的一个虚拟机上运行，对程序来说看起来是一样的。对。
Yeah, exactly. And they're able to do that and make it because of some of the decisions that Sun made. And also, I mean, Sun did open source Java in 2006. So even though they own it and they can still continue to make updates, it gets so subtle. I still don't understand exactly the problems. Like a lot of people are unhappy with the way they open sourced it. But other people are saying like this is a groundbreaking step that they did open source it and make it available for other people to use and modify and build on top of.
是的，完全正确。他们能够做到这一点并实现它，是因为 Sun 做出的一些决定。而且，我的意思是，Sun 在 2006 年开源了 Java。所以即使他们拥有它，他们仍然可以继续进行更新，它变得非常微妙。我仍然不完全理解这些问题。比如很多人对他们开源的方式不满意。但其他人说，他们开源并使其可供其他人使用、修改和构建，这是一个开创性的步骤。
But needless to say, I mean, they made an effort. They did some open sourcing. They revealed a lot of stuff. People can come in and make changes and use it and kind of change it for their own. And, you know, that's kind of an interesting thing, and it's kind of cool. And, you know, Oracle bought Sun, who was creating Java, and some things seem to have changed in the way that they will agree or let people do. But ignoring that, I mean, I feel like Java has really changed a lot from the way I remember it,
但不用说，我的意思是，他们做出了努力。他们做了一些开源。他们揭示了很多东西。人们可以进来进行更改并使用它，并以某种方式为自己改变它。而且，你知道，这是一件有趣的事情，而且很酷。而且，你知道，Oracle 收购了 Sun，Sun 是 Java 的创造者，有些事情似乎在他们同意或让人们做的事情上发生了变化。但忽略这一点，我的意思是，我觉得 Java 确实从我记忆中的样子改变了很多，
like what it used to be used for and where it went, and then what it is used for today. I guess that speaks to the flexibility. It hasn't fallen by the wayside. Yep. And I think that a lot of the research in just... So one thing Java has, and we'll kind of touch on different things as we talk about it and keep the dialogue going, is a just-in-time compiler. And so this is a little bit complicated, but basically the way it works is, you know, Java will look ahead. So the virtual machine is sitting there executing your code, and it's doing like if statements and going to different places.
比如它过去被用来做什么，它去了哪里，以及它今天被用来做什么。我想这说明了灵活性。它没有被淘汰。是的。而且我认为很多研究仅仅是……所以 Java 有一件事，我们会在谈论它时触及不同的事情并保持对话，那就是即时编译器。所以这有点复杂，但基本上它的工作方式是，你知道，Java 会向前看。所以虚拟机坐在那里执行你的代码，它在做 if 语句并去不同的地方。
It's executing the already semi-compiled version of your code. Right, yeah. The version in Java assembly. Yeah, the bytecode. Yeah, so it's executing the bytecode, and it can look ahead and say, hey, you know, you don't have an if statement coming up for a while. Like the next 30 instructions, they're guaranteed to run. Let's say the next 1,000 instructions before you get to an if or a branch.
它正在执行你代码的已经半编译版本。对，是的。Java 汇编版本。是的，字节码。是的，所以它正在执行字节码，它可以向前看并说：“嘿，你知道，你有一段时间没有 if 语句了。”比如接下来的 30 条指令，它们保证会运行。假设在到达 if 或分支之前有接下来的 1,000 条指令。
So let's see if we can do something clever. Like maybe these 30 instructions, they're all ads, And they're all around the same place in memory. So we can send it to what's called a SIMD, single instruction, multiple data. We can send it to a SIMD processor. All 30 of these instructions can go to a processor that can do it all in one step. And so Java could do all these really clever things.
所以让我们看看我们是否能做些聪明的事情。比如这 30 条指令，它们都是加法，而且它们都在内存中的同一个地方。所以我们可以把它发送到所谓的 SIMD，单指令多数据。我们可以把它发送到 SIMD 处理器。所有这 30 条指令都可以发送到一个可以在一步中完成所有这些的处理器。所以 Java 可以做所有这些非常聪明的事情。
And do that at runtime, based on the hardware it's running on. Yeah, exactly. And do it right a little bit ahead of just in time. Just a little bit ahead of your program. So, a lot of that research came about because the virtual machine was open source and people
并在运行时根据它运行的硬件来做。是的，完全正确。并在你的程序之前一点点完成。所以，很多研究之所以出现，是因为虚拟机是开源的，人们
could hack it and do all sorts of interesting things. University students could go through and make all sorts of crazy optimizations and do a lot of experimenting. And Java has always been really synonymous with academia since the beginning. Yeah. I mean, when I was in college, that was the de facto language of algorithms and data structures, those classes. That's what we learned. We learned in Java. And then it seems like today they've backed off a little, some of the universities, to acknowledging that C++ still has a place and there are a lot of companies still using it. And
能够驾驭它并做出各种有趣的事情。大学生可以深入研究，进行各种疯狂的优化和大量的实验。而且从一开始，Java 就一直是学术界的代名词。是的。我的意思是，我在上大学时，它就是算法和数据结构课程的事实标准语言。我们就是那样学的。我们用 Java 学习。而现在看来，一些大学似乎有所退步，开始承认 C++ 仍然有一席之地，而且仍有许多公司在使用它。并且
so teaching more C++. But the only course I had where you needed to know C or C++ was operating systems. Yeah, I was the same way. And even in operating systems, we still wrote some Java for a lot of the multi-threading example stuff. But for like all of the, a lot of the very, very low level stuff, we had to write C, which was many people's first time of ever using c yeah that's a scary experience yeah i remember the first time i saw uh in c somebody casted like uh he had a character array and he wanted to put a struct in the array uh because the character is just representing a block of memory. And he casted the character array to like a struct pointer. And I was like, you can't do that. I was like, what's going on here, you know?
所以开始教授更多的 C++。但我唯一需要了解 C 或 C++ 的课程是操作系统。是的，我也是一样。即使在操作系统课上，我们仍然用 Java 编写了一些多线程示例。但对于所有那些非常非常底层的代码，我们必须用 C 语言编写，这对许多人来说是第一次使用 C。是的，那是一次可怕的经历。是的，我记得第一次看到有人在 C 语言中进行强制类型转换，他有一个字符数组，他想把一个结构体放入数组中，因为字符只是代表了一块内存。他把字符数组转换成了结构体指针。我当时想，你不能那样做。我心想，这到底是怎么回事？
And so it's because Java is so much more strict, you know. But from its strictness, I think, is sort of an elegance. I actually kind of really like that part of it. And one of the things which, you know, I guess we'll get to later is Java is really strict about you doing exceptions and making sure things are the right type and things like that. And I feel like that for new, for people who are new to programming, that sort of builds the right habits, you know? So I feel, I still feel like Java is a good language to teach like at the university level.
所以这是因为 Java 要严格得多。但我认为，这种严格性中有一种优雅。我其实很喜欢这一部分。其中一点，我想我们稍后会谈到，就是 Java 在异常处理、确保类型正确等方面非常严格。我觉得对于编程新手来说，这能培养出正确的习惯。所以我仍然觉得 Java 是一门适合在大学层面教授的语言。
Yeah, I agree. It's kind of interesting to see because I learned C++ first and then did most of my learning in Java at the university. But still, I came into it with thinking about things in terms of pointers and memory layout and the kinds of things that you get drilled into in C++
是的，我同意。这很有趣，因为我先学了 C++，然后在大学里大部分时间都在学 Java。但我进入 Java 时，仍然是用指针、内存布局以及在 C++ 中被反复灌输的那种思维方式来思考问题。
because if you mess them up, you have to learn them early. And if you mess them up, the end results are really painful. So this kind of memory management versus comparing that to somebody who learned Java from the start and then tried to write in C++ and really struggling with pointers and pointer indirection. So it's kind of there's pros and cons to both because I do things in Java sometimes. It's like you don't really need to do that because it handles it.
因为如果你搞砸了，你必须尽早学会。如果你搞砸了，后果会非常痛苦。所以，将这种内存管理与从一开始就学 Java、然后尝试用 C++ 编写代码并为指针和指针间接寻址而苦苦挣扎的人进行比较。所以两者各有利弊，因为我有时在 Java 中做一些事情，会觉得其实没必要这样做，因为它会自动处理。
But it's because I'm used to it. I need to do it this way because else my C++ program is going to blow up. Yeah, exactly. So even to this day, I carry forward some of the things. So it's interesting to talk about what language you should learn on that will be easy for you, help you get through the most important and interesting parts, and then leave you set up for the best place for your future.
但这是因为我习惯了。我需要这样做，否则我的 C++ 程序就会崩溃。是的，完全正确。所以直到今天，我仍然沿用一些习惯。因此，讨论你应该学习哪种语言，既能让你轻松上手，又能帮助你掌握最重要和最有趣的部分，并为你未来的发展打下最好的基础，是一件很有趣的事情。
Yeah, I mean, a professor at my old university was asking me the other day if he should teach Java or Python to new students. And I still felt like Java is the way to go, because with Python, you have sort of a lot more freedom. But you know, when you're new, like a lot of that freedom you can use to sort of make bad code. So Java sort of forces you to follow a certain structure. And even if the structure, depending on what program you're writing, isn't good. Like let's say you're writing some kind of control loop or some kind of thing to generate reports.
是的，我以前大学的一位教授前几天问我，他应该教新生 Java 还是 Python。我仍然觉得 Java 是首选，因为使用 Python，你会有更多的自由。但你知道，当你还是新手时，很多自由可能会被用来写出糟糕的代码。所以 Java 强制你遵循某种结构。即使这种结构根据你编写的程序不同，可能并不总是最好的。比如，假设你正在编写某种控制循环或生成报告的东西。
Maybe Python would be the way to go because you want to constantly be changing it. But still, to write it in Java and follow a certain framework can sort of give you the discipline you need to then go to other languages and not like make a complete mess of it, you know. Except Perl, you'll always make a mess if you're writing Perl. Yeah, it is true. Sometimes that rigor does, you know, it's like you can always write the class and talk about like, hey, how am I going to define this class and what are the interfaces going
也许 Python 会是更好的选择，因为你需要不断地修改它。但即便如此，用 Java 编写并遵循某种框架，可以为你提供所需的纪律，让你在转向其他语言时不会把代码写得一团糟。除了 Perl，如果你写 Perl，你总是会写得一团糟。是的，确实如此。有时那种严谨性确实……就像你总是可以编写类，讨论“嘿，我该如何定义这个类，接口将是什么？”
to be? And writing in something like Java or even C++, well, fortunately that versus like Python, you more get into the idea of just scripting. Like, I'm just going to start writing a script to do this. And then, oh, wait, I actually do need an object. Well, let me go create. It's kind of like, you know, growing up in school, you always told
而在 Java 甚至 C++ 中编写代码，幸运的是，这与 Python 不同，你更多地进入了脚本编写的思维模式。就像，“我只是要开始写一个脚本来做这件事。”然后，“哦，等等，我确实需要一个对象。”好吧，让我去创建它。这有点像，你知道，在学校成长过程中，老师总是告诉你
you got to write your outline before you write your paper. And I feel like I always did terrible at that. I always just wrote the paper and then wrote my outline based on what the paper was. But I do appreciate what they were trying to get into me and what I should have done and how it would have been so much better to sit down and think about stuff. And so sometimes object oriented stuff does help with
在写论文之前必须先写大纲。我觉得我在这方面总是做得一团糟。我总是先写完论文，然后根据论文内容再写大纲。但我确实很欣赏他们试图灌输给我的东西，以及我本应该做的事情，如果能坐下来好好思考一下，情况会好得多。所以有时面向对象的概念确实有助于
that, kind of giving a structure and outline to your code. Yeah, yeah, totally. So some of the features that Java has, we talked about some of them already, but generics. So, what is the idea of a generic? That sounds like a really bland topic.
这一点，为你的代码提供了一种结构和大纲。是的，完全同意。所以 Java 的一些特性，我们已经讨论过一些了，比如泛型。那么，泛型的概念是什么？这听起来是一个非常枯燥的话题。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, generics is, that's a tough one to explain, but I'll give it my best shot. That's why I asked you. Oh, nice. It's totally awesome. So, first, I guess the best way to explain generics is to give a use case, right? Okay, let's go.
是的。是的。是的，泛型是一个很难解释的话题，但我会尽力而为。这就是我问你的原因。哦，不错。这太棒了。所以，首先，我认为解释泛型的最好方法是给出一个用例，对吧？好的，开始吧。
Let's say you wanted to create a list. So not you want a list in your program, but you actually want to create the concept of a list. Like you want to make a list class, right? So you don't want to have a list of integers. You don't want to have a list of integers. You want to have, like, my class int list, and then, you know, under the hood, it could be an array of integers that, you know, resizes or something like that. And then have another class called double list and a float list and things like that. What you really want is, as we talked about in the C++ podcast, you want basically templates.
假设你想创建一个列表。不是说你想在程序中使用列表，而是你实际上想创建列表的概念。比如你想制作一个列表类，对吧？所以你不想只拥有一个整数列表。你不想拥有一个整数列表。你想要的是，比如，我的类 int list，然后，你知道，在底层，它可能是一个整数数组，可以调整大小之类的。然后还要有另一个类叫 double list 和 float list 之类的。你真正想要的是，正如我们在 C++ 播客中讨论的那样，你基本上想要的是模板。
So you want to say, this is my list of type e whatever he is and then later on you want to say okay I want a list of ints I want a list of you know doubles on a list of floats and your custom classes yeah yeah a list of like JSON objects or whatever and you want the system to be able to understand what you mean. So generics are different than templates, but generics, in the end, give you the same end goal. It's trying to get at the same thing, but doing it in a different way.
所以你想说，这是我的 E 类型列表，无论 E 是什么，然后稍后你想说，好的，我想要一个整数列表，我想要一个双精度浮点数列表，我想要一个浮点数列表，还有你的自定义类。是的，是的，一个 JSON 对象列表之类的，你希望系统能够理解你的意思。所以泛型与模板不同，但泛型最终能达到相同的目标。它试图实现同样的事情，但方式不同。
Right, so to explain the differences, in the case of templates, what the C++ compiler will do is, if you say, I want a list of doubles, the compiler will say, have you ever asked for a list of doubles before oh you haven't okay let's take all the list code which is you know list of e which is where he's my template let's make a copy of this code and everywhere I see e I'm gonna replace it with double
对，所以为了解释区别，在模板的情况下，C++ 编译器会做的是，如果你说，我想要一个双精度浮点数列表，编译器会说，你以前要求过双精度浮点数列表吗？哦，你没有，好的，让我们获取所有的列表代码，也就是 list of E，这是我的模板，让我们复制这段代码，在我看到 E 的地方，我都会把它替换成 double。
with literally just like a find replace on that copy of the code and then I'm going to use that reference so you actually have like duplicate copies of the code one for each type that you're using in the case of C++ now in the case of Java with the generic it it actually works kind of differently so the instead of being that sort of low level, it will still have the notion of E all the way through. But when you go to create a list of, let's say, doubles, the compiler knows that this specific list, if you say list double Patrick list,
字面上就像在那份代码副本上进行查找替换，然后我将使用该引用，所以你实际上拥有了代码的重复副本，每种你使用的类型都有一份。在 C++ 的情况下是这样。现在在 Java 的泛型情况下，它实际上工作方式有点不同。所以它不是那种低级别的，它仍然会自始至终保留 E 的概念。但是当你去创建一个列表，比如说，双精度浮点数列表时，编译器知道这个特定的列表，如果你说 list double Patrick list，
Patrick list push 1.0 or something like that. So it knows that Patrick list is a double list and it's not an end list but it still only has one copy of the code so this is kind of like it seems like it's like really pedantic like it's sort of a nuance but the end result is that it's you pay a performance hit so generics are not as fast as templates. Like in C++, you could use a template, and it's like universally better. But in Java, in the case of generics, you are paying a little bit of an overhead price there.
Patrick list push 1.0 之类的。所以它知道 Patrick list 是一个双精度浮点数列表，而不是一个整数列表，但它仍然只有一份代码副本。所以这看起来有点像……这非常迂腐，这是一种细微差别，但最终结果是你需要付出性能代价，所以泛型不如模板快。就像在 C++ 中，你可以使用模板，它在各方面都更好。但在 Java 中，对于泛型，你确实需要支付一点开销。
That was a good summary. It is one of those things that is subtle in what exactly you're allowed to do and not allowed to do at compile time versus run time when you instantiate an object. It gets very subtle and the differences, but I think you summed it up. In the end, it tries to get at the same goal.
那是一个很好的总结。这确实是那种在编译时与运行时实例化对象时，允许做什么和不允许做什么都很微妙的事情。它变得非常微妙，差异也很大，但我认为你总结得很好。最终，它试图达到相同的目标。
How do I write code that applies to many different kinds of objects? Yeah, the only other subtle difference between generics and templates, with templates, you can put anything. Like you could have a template because it's just going to do a find replace, right? You could have a template and then template put one. So you could have, for example, let's say you had a class called array.
我该如何编写适用于多种不同类型对象的代码？是的，泛型和模板之间唯一的另一个细微区别是，使用模板，你可以放入任何东西。你可以有一个模板，因为它只是进行查找替换，对吧？你可以有一个模板，然后模板放入 1。所以你可以有，例如，假设你有一个名为 array 的类。
Actually, boost has this class called array. And the template parameters, one is the types. You can put int, float, whatever. And the second template parameter is literally a number. So you can say, like, boost array. You know, this is in C++. You can say boost array bracket int comma 100. And it will create an array of size 100.
实际上，Boost 库有一个名为 array 的类。模板参数之一是类型。你可以放入 int、float 等等。第二个模板参数字面上是一个数字。所以你可以说，比如，boost array。你知道，这是在 C++ 中。你可以说 boost array 。它将创建一个大小为 100 的数组。
In Java, you can't do that. So all of the, you know, quote, unquote, templates, all the generics in Java have to be types. And so that's a subtle difference, but it can have, again, like some implications on performance. So, all right, that's generics. Why don't you cover garbage collection? So garbage collection in C++, if you – so there are two kinds of memory, right? There's static and dynamic.
在 Java 中，你不能那样做。所以所有的，你知道，所谓的模板，Java 中的所有泛型都必须是类型。所以这是一个细微的区别，但它可能再次对性能产生一些影响。所以，好吧，这就是泛型。你为什么不介绍一下垃圾回收？所以 C++ 中的垃圾回收，如果你——所以有两种内存，对吧？静态内存和动态内存。
There's I know I need to hold the value of an average of a number of items in a list. So what is the average of all of the numbers in my list, which are heights of various trees in the forest? I like to think of colorful examples. So all the heights of all the trees in the forest. But you don't know how many trees are in the forest when you write your program. You want a program that can work for any forest, maybe a big forest, maybe a small forest, maybe a park, maybe your backyard.
我知道我需要保存列表中多个项目平均值的数值。那么，我列表中所有数字的平均值是多少？这些数字是森林中各种树木的高度。我喜欢用色彩丰富的例子。所以是森林中所有树木的高度。但当你编写程序时，你不知道森林里有多少棵树。你想要一个可以适用于任何森林的程序，也许是一个大森林，也许是一个小森林，也许是一个公园，也许是你的后院。
I don't know if your backyard can be considered a forest. But anyways, you want to be able to count up and average all of the heights of the trees. So you know you want a numerator and a denominator, so you can do the sum of the heights divided by the number of trees. That's how you're going to get your average height. So you know you need these two things, and you know you need to store the output. So those are your static variables, the variables you know in advance you're going to get your average height. So you know you need these two things, and you know you need to store the output. So those are your static variables, the variables you know in advance you're going to need. But then dynamically, you need to be able to say, I'm going to have 100 tree heights.
我不知道你的后院是否可以被视为森林。但无论如何，你想要能够计算并平均所有树木的高度。所以你知道你需要一个分子和一个分母，这样你就可以用高度之和除以树木的数量。这就是你得到平均高度的方法。所以你知道你需要这两样东西，而且你知道你需要存储输出。所以这些是你的静态变量，你预先知道你需要存储平均高度的变量。所以你知道你需要这两样东西，而且你知道你需要存储输出。所以这些是你的静态变量，你预先知道你需要用到的变量。但动态地，你需要能够说，我将有 100 个树高。
I'm going to have 5 tree heights. I'm going to have 1,000 tree heights. And so in C++, this is done with the new and delete. So when you say at runtime, somebody has to tell you, okay, I'm passing you in a list and you go, okay, well, how long is that list? Oh, that list is a thousand trees. You know, okay, well then I need to create a thousand heights item slots and I go create them. And then that I do that with the new. And what it does is instead of where static memory comes from one play, we won't get into the super big, but like one operating system has one pool of memory for static and another pool for dynamic, which is pretty big.
我将有 5 个树高。我将有 1,000 个树高。所以在 C++ 中，这是通过 new 和 delete 完成的。所以当你在运行时说，有人必须告诉你，好的，我传给你一个列表，然后你说，好的，那个列表有多长？哦，那个列表有一千棵树。你知道，好的，那么我需要创建一千个高度项目槽位，然后我去创建它们。我用 new 来做这件事。它的作用是，不是像静态内存那样来自一个地方，我们不会深入探讨超级大的细节，但操作系统有一个用于静态内存的内存池，另一个用于动态内存的内存池，这相当大。
And so it goes and grabs you some random chunk out of this big pool and gives it to you and says, here you go. Here, you can stick all of your trees in this random chunk of memory that I gave you. That's contiguous memory. It's all in a row, but it could be anywhere. It doesn't give you a guarantee about where it is. And then you get that. And if you can't get it, you're out of memory. And you
所以它会去从这个大池子里抓取一些随机的块给你，然后说，给你。在这里，你可以把你所有的树都塞进我给你的这块随机内存里。那是连续的内存。它们都在一行里，但它可能在任何地方。它不会给你关于它在哪里的保证。然后你得到了它。如果你得不到，你就是内存不足。然后你
typically, that's what you get out of memory exception, because there's no memory for you to dynamically allocate. So you allocate that memory, then you fill it with your numbers, you do your division, and then you need to make sure to free it. If you don't free it, this pool of memory that's for everybody across the whole operating systems, dynamic allocations, then they can't use it. And it'll just stay, the operating system will just assume that's always being used forever, you know, and that it's, it may be, you really need to keep it there for a really long time. And so it won't go and free it for you. And so if you have a program that runs for a long, and then the operating systems will get smart and kind of say, oh, your program's dead. Like I can go free it or try to do
通常，这就是你得到内存不足异常的原因，因为没有内存供你动态分配。所以你分配了那块内存，然后你用数字填充它，你做除法，然后你需要确保释放它。如果你不释放它，这个供整个操作系统所有动态分配使用的内存池，别人就无法使用它。它就会一直留在那里，操作系统会一直假设它永远被占用，你知道，而且它可能，你确实需要把它留在那里很长一段时间。所以它不会为你释放它。所以如果你的程序运行了很长时间，然后操作系统会变得聪明，说，哦，你的程序死了。我可以去释放它或者尝试做
various clever things. But ultimately if your program's running for a long time and you continue to call this function over and over again, you'll keep what's called leaking memory. So the idea in Java is say, well that's a pain, people inevitably forget to free all of their memory, they don't do it in the right time, you free it too early and then somebody else uses it, and then Jason goes to read data that I told him that I put there and in reality it's no longer there and he reads something else he's not supposed to. So in Java they get around this by trying to say instead of this we'll handle all of the allocations for you. You just go use something and when you use something you say
各种巧妙的事情。但最终，如果你的程序运行了很长时间，并且你继续一遍又一遍地调用这个函数，你就会一直发生所谓的内存泄漏。所以 Java 的想法是说，好吧，那太麻烦了，人们不可避免地会忘记释放他们所有的内存，他们没有在正确的时间做这件事，你释放得太早，然后别人又使用了它，然后 Jason 去读取我告诉他我放在那里的数据，实际上它已经不在那里了，他读取了其他他不应该读取的东西。所以在 Java 中，他们通过尝试说，与其这样，不如我们为你处理所有的分配来解决这个问题。你只需要去使用某些东西，当你使用某些东西时，你说
new or whatever and it'll work but then what we're going to do is use various mechanisms such things as like reference counting. So how many things do I have that store the address of the data? So I have five variables that all point to the same data. Well, Java's virtual machine will keep that data marked for you until there's not, you go five to four to three to two, as your static functions are ending, as your program's winding down, whatever. And you begin to not need these variables, it's called what goes out of scope. So when they're no longer,
new 或者其他什么，它就会工作，但我们要做的就是使用各种机制，比如引用计数。所以我有多少东西存储了数据的地址？我有五个变量都指向相同的数据。好吧，Java 的虚拟机将为你标记该数据，直到没有了，你从 5 到 4 到 3 到 2，随着你的静态函数结束，随着你的程序运行结束，等等。当你开始不再需要这些变量时，这被称为超出作用域。所以当它们不再是
there's no way your program can need it in the short term. And once that goes down to zero, that means nobody is using that data anymore. Nobody's pointing to it. So then Java can do what's called garbage collect. It can go through and say, everything that no longer has anybody pointing to it or using it, I can free.
你的程序在短期内不可能需要它。一旦那个数字降到零，这意味着没有人再使用该数据了。没有人指向它。所以 Java 可以做所谓的垃圾回收。它可以遍历并说，所有不再有任何人指向它或使用它的东西，我都可以释放。
And that works great. You don't have to remember what to free. You don't have to remember who's using what. Java just kind of handles it all for you. The issue is that you don't have control over when that happens. And later they really tried to address this, and maybe even from the beginning, but it's just this complicated issue of
这效果很好。你不必记住要释放什么。你不必记住谁在使用什么。Java 只是为你处理了这一切。问题在于你无法控制它何时发生。后来他们确实试图解决这个问题，也许甚至从一开始就想到了，但这只是一个复杂的问题，
if you're trying to do something and you really need it to go now, and Java decides like, I'm going to garbage collect now, then you kind of are stuck waiting until it finishes garbage collecting because it's a really slow process. Yeah, because think about it. Java has to go through every object you've made in your entire program potentially and say like which of these objects are you do you not need anymore and that's an expensive process yeah and so that there are great amounts of research have been done to make
如果你试图做某事，并且你真的需要它现在就执行，而 Java 决定说，我现在要进行垃圾回收，那么你就会被卡住，直到它完成垃圾回收，因为它是一个非常缓慢的过程。是的，因为你想想。Java 可能需要遍历你在整个程序中创建的每一个对象，并说，这些对象中哪些是你不再需要的，这是一个昂贵的过程。是的，所以已经进行了大量的研究来使
this better and faster and do all sorts of awesome things to make this so like even now there's different levels of garbage collection, right? Like a very shallow one. Like, let me just look for things that are really obvious. And if I free up enough for you, great, then I'll stop. But then if, like, I'm out, out, out of memory, like, I get to scan to every last, you know, object and really count them all. And that takes a really long time and can cause your program to pause for seconds or
这一点变得更好、更快，并做各种很棒的事情来使它……即使现在也有不同级别的垃圾回收，对吧？比如非常浅层的。比如，我只寻找那些非常明显的东西。如果我为你释放了足够的空间，太好了，那我就停止。但如果，比如，我内存耗尽了，我必须扫描每一个最后的，你知道，对象，并真正地清点它们。这需要很长时间，并可能导致你的程序暂停几秒钟或
minutes depending, right, on the amount of memory you're using. Yeah, and that's why sometimes in Java you'll get get uh like i think it's out of heap space like a heap like a memory exception called out of heap space and that means that you just don't have enough memory to do whatever you're trying to do like you're allocating too much but there's another exception that you'll get i can't remember the name but it's i think it's just something really generic like heap exception or heap run exception what that means is you know you know you're right on the edge of how much memory you're using. And Java, the garbage collector, is spending so much time doing all these really expensive, deep algorithms to clean out objects. It doesn't have enough time to run your actual program.
几分钟，取决于你使用的内存量。是的，这就是为什么有时在 Java 中你会得到……我想是堆空间不足，像堆一样的内存异常，叫做 out of heap space，这意味着你没有足够的内存来做你正在尝试做的事情，比如你分配了太多。但还有另一个异常你会得到，我不记得名字了，但我认为它只是像堆异常或堆运行异常这样非常通用的东西。它的意思是，你知道，你正处于你使用的内存量的边缘。而 Java 的垃圾回收器花费了太多时间在所有这些非常昂贵、深入的算法上来清理对象。它没有足够的时间来运行你的实际程序。
And so you'll actually get either of these now, but basically most of the time the solution is to give yourself more memory. Yeah. So, I mean, this is an interesting feature of Java. This is the first time I remember this really coming into controversy because, you know, early on, this is a big deal. Like if your program had to sit there and garbage collect, you could really, you know, toast. Like if you think about if you're trying to write a game, you have to, one, if you're going to run it at 30 frames a second or 60 frames a second, every 1 60th of a second, you have
所以你现在实际上会得到其中任何一个，但基本上大多数时候解决方案是给自己更多的内存。是的。所以，我的意思是，这是 Java 的一个有趣特性。这是我记得第一次这真的引起争议，因为，你知道，早期，这是一个大问题。如果你的程序必须坐在那里进行垃圾回收，你真的会，你知道，完蛋。如果你想想如果你试图写一个游戏，你必须，第一，如果你要以每秒 30 帧或 60 帧的速度运行它，每 1/60 秒，你必须
to draw something on the screen or else people see it as a stutter. And if Java decides to go garbage collect at a bad time and make you skip a couple frames, you're going to get a stutter and people are going to not like your game as much. Yep. Java also has interfaces.
在屏幕上画点什么，否则人们会觉得它卡顿。如果 Java 决定在糟糕的时间进行垃圾回收并让你跳过几帧，你就会得到卡顿，人们就不会那么喜欢你的游戏了。是的。Java 也有接口。
So one thing that you have in C++ that you don't in Java is multiple inheritance. So in C++, you can have three different classes, and one class inherit from all those classes and get all of the functions and all of the data objects and everything. And Java said, we're not going to allow that, because that causes a lot of problems.
所以你在 C++ 中有而 Java 中没有的一件事是多重继承。所以，在 C++ 中，你可以有三个不同的类，一个类可以继承所有这些类，并获得所有的函数、数据对象和一切。而 Java 说，我们不允许这样做，因为那会导致很多问题。
Yeah, so the biggest problem with multiple inheritance is what's called the diamond problem have you heard of this uh i probably know it by a different name so why don't you explain it so yeah i'm going to do my best this is going to be tough but so basically the diamond problem is when um you have so because of multiple inheritance you have two things that you're inheriting both of those have a common parent and they both override some method foo of that parent and then you call super dot foo like which one should it call that's the issue so to try and give an example which is gonna be really hard but let's say let's say you have a game object which is this is your player
是的，所以多重继承最大的问题是所谓的菱形问题，你听说过这个吗？呃，我可能用不同的名字知道它，所以你为什么不解释一下？所以，是的，我会尽力，这会很困难，但基本上菱形问题是当你……因为多重继承，你有两样东西你正在继承，这两者都有一个共同的父类，并且它们都重写了该父类的某个方法 foo，然后你调用 super.foo，它应该调用哪一个？这就是问题所在。所以为了尝试给出一个例子，这会非常困难，但假设，假设你有一个游戏对象，这是你的玩家
in some game right and game object inherits from like physics object because your player has some physics he jumps and his velocity changes and things like that game object also inherits from let's say like player or player object also inherits from entity, which entity is like
在某个游戏中，对吧？游戏对象继承自物理对象，因为你的玩家有一些物理属性，他会跳跃，他的速度会改变之类的。游戏对象也继承自，比如说，玩家，或者玩家对象也继承自实体，实体就像
includes players and enemies and has things like hit points and like animations and things like that. So you have you have your player object, it inherits from, you know, entity and from physics object, and entity and physics object they both inherit from drawable so there's so a physics object can be drawn and an entity can be drawn and so now your player object calls you know parent draw or just calls the draw function
包括玩家和敌人，并且有生命值和动画之类的东西。所以你有你的玩家对象，它继承自，你知道，实体和物理对象，而实体和物理对象它们都继承自可绘制对象，所以有一个……所以物理对象可以被绘制，实体也可以被绘制，所以现在你的玩家对象调用，你知道，父类绘制，或者只是调用绘制函数
well like which one should it call you know because the physics object has a way of drawing and the physics object has a way of drawing, and the entity has a way of drawing the animations, and you haven't really specified, and the language doesn't really give you a way to say, oh, from these two things I'm inheriting, pick this one, right? Or even worse, someone outside of you calls the draw function, right?
嗯，它应该调用哪一个？你知道，因为物理对象有一种绘制方式，物理对象有一种绘制方式，而实体有一种绘制动画的方式，你并没有真正指定，而且语言也没有给你一种方式来说，哦，从我继承的这两个东西中，选择这一个，对吧？或者更糟的是，你之外的某个人调用了绘制函数，对吧？
Which one should it use? So this is one of these fundamentally broken aspects of multiple inheritance there's pretty much no way to fix it's a design thing you have to design it so you don't let this happen yeah you basically yeah yes exactly right you just you cannot have that in your code so um if you have if you have that situation you just have to hope that the things you're inheriting from that you have access to that code and you can fix that so like if physics object was someone else's library like the havoc physics engine and like you know the entity was part of like some like the source engine from valve or whatever like you couldn't inherit from both of those at the same time
它应该使用哪一个？所以这是多重继承中这些根本上被破坏的方面之一，几乎没有办法修复。这是一个设计问题，你必须设计它，这样你就不会让这种情况发生。是的，你基本上……是的，完全正确。你只是……你不能在你的代码中有那个。所以，嗯，如果你有那种情况，你只能希望你继承的东西，你有权访问那些代码，并且你可以修复它。所以，如果物理对象是别人的库，比如 Havok 物理引擎，而实体是 Valve 的 Source 引擎的一部分之类的，你不能同时继承这两个
without causing the diamond problem so j Java gets around that by using interfaces. And so the idea here with interfaces is you can only have one parent. Like you can only have one way inheritance. You can't have multiple inheritance. But they understand that you might want to do, like the example I gave, you might want to have an abstract the example I gave, you might want to have an abstract physics object for all of your players and an abstract drawable object for all your players. And you want the players to inherit both of those.
而不导致菱形问题。所以 Java 通过使用接口来绕过这个问题。所以这里的接口概念是，你只能有一个父类。就像你只能有单继承。你不能有多重继承。但他们明白你可能想做，就像我给出的例子，你可能想有一个抽象的物理对象给所有的玩家，还有一个抽象的可绘制对象给所有的玩家。而且你希望玩家继承这两者。
So Java adds this thing called interfaces. And interfaces, they're not allowed to have any code in them. And all of the methods have to be subsequently you have to be virtual but because of that they get around this diamond problem because you don't have any there's no code to be ambiguous about yeah exactly so you know if you have 10 different interfaces and then you have your parent and you call the draw function the draw function only exists in one of those 11 objects, right? Because the rest are all abstract. So Java also has checked exceptions.
所以 Java 添加了这个叫做接口的东西。而且接口，它们不允许包含任何代码。并且所有的函数都必须是……随后你必须是虚函数，但正因为如此，它们绕过了这个菱形问题，因为你没有任何……没有代码会产生歧义。是的，完全正确。所以你知道，如果你有 10 个不同的接口，然后你有你的父类，你调用绘制函数，绘制函数只存在于那 11 个对象中的一个里，对吧？因为其余的都是抽象的。所以 Java 也有受检异常。
So C++ has later come to have exceptions and tries to have exception handling. But Java really kind of did how the gate did it. Like we're going to have exceptions and you can throw an exception in your code and then code that's calling your code can check for that exception and handle it or allow the person above you to handle it. Yeah. And kind of really do this as a way to say what happens when something goes wrong in your program, which is important as a programmer.
所以 C++ 后来也有了异常，并试图进行异常处理。但 Java 确实是那样做的。就像我们要有异常，你可以在你的代码中抛出异常，然后调用你代码的代码可以检查该异常并处理它，或者允许你上面的人处理它。是的。并且真正以这种方式来表达当你的程序中出现问题时会发生什么，这作为程序员是很重要的。
And we can't keep going into deep on all of these, but we'll make you here for like four hours. Oh, yeah, it's true. It doesn't mean to us. But it really is important as a programmer to think about not just when things go right, but what happens when things go wrong. And I think too often as programmers, we forget to think about not just when things go right, but what happens when things go wrong. And I think too often as programmers, we forget to think about that in advance.
我们不能继续深入探讨所有这些，否则我们会让你在这里待上四个小时。哦，是的，确实如此。这对我们来说没什么。但作为程序员，思考不仅是当事情顺利时，而且当事情出错时会发生什么，这真的很重要。而且我认为作为程序员，我们太经常忘记思考
We always just assume it's the happy, wonderful pony and rainbow world, right? Where everything magically works and we don't spend enough time handling what happens when things don't work. Yep, and Java will actually force you to catch an exception. Like in C++, you can always just not catch things and it'll just cause your program to crash.
我们总是假设这是一个快乐、美妙的小马和彩虹世界，对吧？在那里一切神奇地工作，我们没有花足够的时间处理当事情不工作时会发生什么。是的，而且 Java 实际上会强制你捕获异常。就像在 C++ 中，你总是可以不捕获任何东西，它只会导致你的程序崩溃。
But in Java, it'll force you to do something about it. You either have to catch it or you have to throw it against. You have to say, I'm going to catch this thing, or I'm telling the person above me that they have to catch it. Yep. The only way you can actually, it's not even really a crash, but the only way you can halt your program is by throwing the exception all the way up to main
但在 Java 中，它会强制你对此做点什么。你要么必须捕获它，要么必须抛出它。你必须说，我要捕获这个东西，或者我告诉上面的人他们必须捕获它。是的。你实际上唯一能做的，它甚至不是真正的崩溃，但你唯一能停止程序的方法是把异常一直抛到 main
and then throwing it through main. And then you'll actually cause your whole program to halt. But in C++, unless you do something special by default, you're going to kill the program with an exception. So yeah, we should probably blow through
然后通过 main 抛出它。然后你实际上会导致整个程序停止。但在 C++ 中，除非你做一些特别的事情，否则默认情况下，你会用一个异常杀死程序。所以是的，我们可能应该快速过一下
these strengths that we've missed this year because we are... So we talked about platform agnostic. Java's got huge uh community support there's lots of people what many big companies use java libraries and anything you could want yeah example code support forums it's great yeah weakness it used to be speed you know java used to be slow and that was probably fairly true in the early days now it depends on what you're trying to do. It may or may not matter.
我们今年错过的这些优势，因为我们……所以我们谈到了平台无关性。Java 有巨大的社区支持，有很多人，许多大公司使用 Java 库，任何你想要的东西都有，是的，示例代码、支持论坛，这很棒。是的，弱点是过去的速度，你知道，Java 过去很慢，这在早期可能相当真实。现在这取决于你试图做什么。它可能重要，也可能不重要。
Yeah, I honestly have not seen it matter in anything I've done recently. But yeah, I actually wrote a graphics engine in Java way back and speed was an issue back then. But now it's just... Yeah, and that's both because computers got faster and also Java got more optimal, more optimized. So hardware abstraction.
是的，老实说，在我最近做的任何事情中，我都没有看到它有什么影响。但是的，我确实在很久以前用 Java 写过一个图形引擎，当时速度确实是个问题。但现在它只是……是的，这既是因为计算机变快了，也是因为 Java 变得更优化了。所以硬件抽象。
So Platform Agnostic was a pro. Hardware abstraction, you don't have a lot of insight into what your hardware is really doing. So it makes certain kinds of programs very difficult or impossible to write. Yeah, and you can't, I mean, for example, you couldn't talk to the Kinect or something, right, in Java. Unless somebody else wrote a library that interpreted that for you. Right, exactly. Which we can't get into how you do that yeah let's let's get that but like yeah you'd have you'd have to write something in c
所以平台无关性是一个优点。硬件抽象，你对你的硬件到底在做什么没有太多的洞察。所以这使得某些类型的程序非常困难或不可能编写。是的，而且你不能，我的意思是，例如，你不能在 Java 中与 Kinect 对话之类的，对吧？除非别人为你写了一个库来解释它。对，完全正确。我们不能深入探讨你是怎么做到的，是的，让我们……但就像，是的，你必须用 C 编写一些东西
to talk to the connect and then talk to that in java basically yeah so the other weakness is uh it forces you to be object oriented you know which is a strength but also weakness i mean it's not doesn't let you be functional like in the case of C or C++, I can do function pointers. I could pass functions around. If I wanted something like MapReduce, for example, I could pass a map function to MapReduce. And that kind of makes sense. It's like, here's this, here's this pointer to this block of code. In the case of Java, if I want to use like Hadoop or MapReduce or something like that, I have to create this map object that doesn't have anything but a function in it. And so it's not that big a deal,
来与 Kinect 对话，然后基本上在 Java 中与它对话。是的，所以另一个弱点是它强制你面向对象，你知道，这是一个优势，但也是一个弱点。我的意思是，它不允许你进行函数式编程，就像在 C 或 C++ 的情况下，我可以做函数指针。我可以传递函数。如果我想要像 MapReduce 这样的东西，例如，我可以传递一个 map 函数给 MapReduce。这很有意义。就像，这是这个，这是这个代码块的指针。在 Java 的情况下，如果我想使用像 Hadoop 或 MapReduce 之类的东西，我必须创建这个 map 对象，除了一个函数之外什么都没有。所以这没什么大不了的，
but just knowing that you have to do things in an object-oriented way, that could be a weakness. And that's a limitation to certain people, certain times it can be frustrating, but of the language, not of the virtual machine. Right. Because when we talk about, but of the language, not of the virtual machine. Right. Because when we talk about other languages in the future, other languages are purely functional and implemented on the same virtual machine that Java uses.
但仅仅知道你必须以面向对象的方式做事，这可能是一个弱点。这对某些人来说是一个限制，有时会令人沮丧，但这是语言的限制，而不是虚拟机的限制。对。因为当我们谈论未来其他语言时，其他语言是纯函数式的，并且在 Java 使用的同一个虚拟机上实现。
Yeah, totally. Foreshadowing. Yeah, exactly. So I like Eclipse for editing my Java code. Yeah, Eclipse is great. If you use NetBeans, that's good too. I used NetBeans for a few years. Eclipse used to be – NetBeans used to be way superior to Eclipse is great. If you use NetBeans, that's good too. I used NetBeans for a few years. Eclipse used to be – NetBeans used to be way superior to Eclipse, you know, in like the early, like, 2000s.
是的，完全同意。伏笔。是的，完全正确。所以我喜欢用 Eclipse 来编辑我的 Java 代码。是的，Eclipse 很棒。如果你使用 NetBeans，那也很好。我用了几年 NetBeans。Eclipse 过去是……NetBeans 过去比 Eclipse 强得多。Eclipse 很棒。如果你使用 NetBeans，那也很好。我用了几年 NetBeans。Eclipse 过去是……NetBeans 过去比 Eclipse 强得多，你知道，在像 2000 年代早期。
But now I think Eclipse is almost universally better. There's still some diehard NetBeans people out there, but they're both great tools. You really just throw it down, man. You just like lay it down. This is better. And then, like, you're just inviting the hate mail. Yeah, I'm sure I'm going to get flamed for that. But you know,
但现在我认为 Eclipse 几乎在各方面都更好。仍然有一些顽固的 NetBeans 用户，但它们都是很棒的工具。你真的只是把它扔出来，伙计。你只是把它摆出来。这更好。然后，就像，你只是在招致仇恨邮件。是的，我肯定会因为那个被喷。但你知道，
I think they're both great tools. You can do great stuff. And there's other ones, many other ones as well. You can always edit the eye. Oh yeah, there's that too. But yeah, there's even more IDEs. Like what was that?
我认为它们都是很棒的工具。你可以做很棒的事情。还有其他的，许多其他的。你总是可以编辑……哦，是的，还有那个。但是的，还有更多的 IDE。比如那是什么？
Bluebird or something. I used BlueJ. Okay. Yeah, that was one that I used in college. But yeah. So Java is used for almost everything except for like applets. Like I see applets now, but like kind of not a very great experience anymore. But server side, Java is used heavily.
Bluebird 之类的。我用过 BlueJ。好的。是的，那是我在大学里用过的一个。但是的。所以 Java 几乎被用于所有事情，除了像 Applet。就像我现在看到 Applet，但就像不再是一个非常好的体验了。但在服务器端，Java 被大量使用。
Yep. So if you ever heard of Tomcat or Java server pages, JSPs or any of that, that's all Java. Now that's different than another way that people write Java for the web, which is like the Google Web Toolkit. Right. Or other such, which is you write Java code and run it through a compiler that generates JavaScript for you. Yep.
是的。所以如果你听说过 Tomcat 或 Java 服务器页面，JSP 或任何这些，那都是 Java。现在这与人们为 Web 编写 Java 的另一种方式不同，比如 Google Web Toolkit。对。或其他类似的，也就是你编写 Java 代码并通过一个为你生成 JavaScript 的编译器运行它。是的。
Yeah. So that's pretty wild, right? So you actually can do client side Java code using Google Web Toolkit. And I've done a little bit of that. It was OK. I think. DAN GALPIN- Yeah, I've never really done it. But what I understand is that Google used that to do Gmail.
是的。所以这很疯狂，对吧？所以你实际上可以使用 Google Web Toolkit 编写客户端 Java 代码。我做过一点。还可以。我想。DAN GALPIN- 是的，我从来没真正做过。但我了解的是，Google 用它来做 Gmail。
Right? So early versions of Gmail or something were done this way. Or to try to do stuff similarly is why they developed this and kind of released it for other people to use. Because it turned out they wanted to make the web a better experience. DAN GALPIN- Yeah, totally. And so that you can write Java code, which you're developed this and kind of released it for other people to use because it turned out they wanted to make the web a better experience. Yeah, yeah, totally.
对吧？所以 Gmail 的早期版本或类似的东西就是这样做的。或者尝试做类似的事情，这就是为什么他们开发了这个并将其发布给其他人使用。因为事实证明他们想让 Web 成为更好的体验。DAN GALPIN- 是的，完全同意。所以你可以编写 Java 代码，你开发了这个并将其发布给其他人使用，因为事实证明他们想让 Web 成为更好的体验。是的，是的，完全同意。
And so that you can write Java code which you're used to writing and it's kind of high level but then it kind of spits out this JavaScript which may not be super readable for a human. Oh, yeah. But will work and your browser knows how to interpret it. Yeah, totally. We also talked about using it for Android. Yep. If you're doing Android, you're almost certainly writing Java.
所以你可以编写你习惯编写的 Java 代码，它有点高级，但它会吐出这种对人类来说可能不太可读的 JavaScript。哦，是的。但它会工作，你的浏览器知道如何解释它。是的，完全同意。我们还谈到了用它来做 Android。是的。如果你在做 Android，你几乎肯定是在写 Java。
Yep. Jason mentioned Hadoop. Yep. Hadoop's all written in Java. So for big data as well, which we haven't really talked a lot about big data. Yeah, maybe we should do a show on big data. That would be great. Yeah.
是的。Jason 提到了 Hadoop。是的。Hadoop 全是用 Java 写的。所以对于大数据也是如此，我们还没有真正谈论太多关于大数据的事情。是的，也许我们应该做一个关于大数据的节目。那会很棒。是的。
That's awesome. We should do that. We're going to add that to the list. The ever-growing list. It's on the priority queue. We got a couple of good, excellent reader. No, listener feedback. So we have some emails we need to respond to as well.
那太棒了。我们应该这样做。我们要把它加到列表中。那个不断增长的列表。它在优先级队列中。我们有几个很好的、优秀的读者。不，听众反馈。所以我们也有一些邮件需要回复。
Some people have emailed us and said some nice comments, giving us reviews on iTunes, showing us the love. Yeah, yeah, thanks, guys, for doing that. It's been awesome. We're definitely going to keep the show going. Yeah, we know we're not being as on the regular frequency as we're supposed to, but we're really trying. We really want to keep it going.
有些人给我们发了邮件，写了一些很好的评论，在iTunes上给我们打分，表达了对我们的喜爱。是的，是的，谢谢大家这样做。这太棒了。我们一定会继续做这个节目。是的，我们知道我们没有按照预定的频率更新，但我们真的在努力。我们真的很想坚持下去。
I think that, you know, we had a little bit of a hiccup with sort of like, we got situated. We have like a new recording studio. Yeah. So that took a little bit of like, you know, getting used to the move and everything. But yeah, we should be able to... We just got to settle back into the groove and we should be back on a better schedule.
我想，你知道，我们遇到了一点小插曲，比如，我们刚安顿下来。我们有了一个新的录音室。是的。所以这花了一些时间来适应搬迁等等。但是，是的，我们应该能够……我们只需要重新找回状态，应该就能回到更好的时间表上了。
Yeah, totally, totally. So that's all I got, man. Until next time. Yeah, have a good one. This is an action-packed episode here. Talking fast at the end. Yeah, totally. So have a good one, guys, totally. So that's all I got, man. Until next time. Yeah, have a good one. This is an action-packed episode here. Talking fast at the end. Yeah, totally. So have a good one, guys, and we'll see you in the next episode. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution ShareAlike 2.0 license.
是的，完全同意。这就是我所有的内容了，伙计。下次见。好的，祝你过得愉快。这一集内容非常丰富。最后说话很快。是的，完全同意。所以祝大家过得愉快，完全同意。这就是我所有的内容了，伙计。下次见。好的，祝你过得愉快。这一集内容非常丰富。最后说话很快。是的，完全同意。所以祝大家过得愉快，我们下一集再见。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。
You're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行重混或改编，但您必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。